Let's do the Darius stuff. This is the Darius stuff. We'll We'll
just hit it. We'll hit the ground running with it. I think Darius
might have even gone live yesterday
if we want to watch Darius's VOD from yesterday and not just
the process stuff where he talked about it. I think we'll go
over to kick only as well. So, this is if you can't see. All
right. It's I know it's not like the best quality. It's cuz they're
driving. So, if you can't see, he's driving on the highway. He
sees cops on the right side in the in the shoulder on the right.
And he decides
he decides, you know what? I don't have to lane switch. I don't
have to slow down. I'm going to blow the doors off these cop
cars in the middle of the night.
>> Doesn't slow down. Doesn't switch lanes.
>> just blows by them in the middle of the night. Okay.
>> I didn't realize you could get pulled over for that.
For not I don't know where you live, homophexual.
Do you live in the United States?
I don't think there's a single I I
I've only been to a couple states, but every single state I went
to, they had a rule about either yielding going to the other
side of traffic if there's construction or police or it was like
slow down. I know where I live, um the fines like 5x or something
if you go by them, right? The fines go up massively
if you're like speeding and you speed by cop cars like this.
And like that's going to also just them off in general. Like
they're going to get extremely at
So if there are laws that prevent you from doing that, if you
are actually speeding, they get you. You're It's November and
hasn't snowed in a Captain C 319.
Is that I feel like you guys have had Halloweens other Halloweens
without snow on the ground. It's like I remember it's basically
a coin flip for Well, it's like 60 70% chance there's snow on
the ground for Halloween, but not a lot of snow.
There's lots of times that um Okay. All right. Super bizaro.
Yeah, Darius did a sonic boom going by them. Yeah, I thought
it was like 7030 for the
at BC. Snow and BC twice so far. Yeah, it's like it's not quite
50/50. Anyway, let's continue. He just sped by him. >> We're
about to be >> Did they turn our lights off after we >> No,
he probably wants to pass it. >> He probably just Did he
shut his lights off and start like running me down? Oh. Um, wait.
Is he Wait, why why are his lights on? He's right behind me.
Huh? >> I mean, he's not making any sound. Game
>> not pull me over. >> No, he's pulling you over.
You got to
turn off stream.
>> Ha. If only.
Okay. He does that for a quick second. He turns off the stream.
All right.
And then >> I don't understand why I'm being arrested.
I just don't >> Oh, dude. I don't I just don't get it.
Now, in his defense, I think in this case, I I believe he might
actually not have needed to be arrested at all. I do think like
a fine would have been fine here, you know? Let's keep watching.
>> I just don't I don't I don't get it.
>> I got I got kids, dude. >> Got kids, dude. >> My
dogs.
I'm okay.
>> I got kids, dog.
>> All right. I got to run her. Okay. Okay. That's fine.
>> They're going to talk to you.
>> Hey. Hey. How you doing?
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. No
>> I'll leave my
Okay. Sorry.
Let's check my phone. My wallet. Yeah. Yeah. Nothing. Nothing
crazy on me. You can check through my shoes. Whatever. So,
uh, De Darius pulling a play out of Destiny's book directly,
sliding the phone into his pocket during an interaction with
the police. Very, very experienced move here. Okay, that's unironically.
I'm pretty sure he says they're like, "What do you have in your
pockets?" He says, "My phone." Just my phone, right?
>> Okay. Sorry.
Just check my phone. My wallet. Yeah. Yeah. My wallet. Nothing.
Nothing crazy on me. Just my phone. Just my wallet. >> I'm
not doing anything crazy.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> So, what this tells me there's like a little bit we
can read into this. Okay. What this what this sounds like to
me is
he decides he's going to do this. He slides the phone into his
pocket.
I think Darius is scared as I do not think he's scared. I think
he's playing this up for stream. I think he's acting this up
for stream because he slid his phone into his pocket. He knows
he's going to try to stream the audio. I think he's acting.
And because he's acting, just watch what happens.
>> Oh, okay. I've been in legal issues before and they
always I get I'm a little little shaken up. I literally I'm 29
years old. I've never had legal stuff until like the last like
6 months or so of my life. So, I just get a little shaken up
whenever
that stuff happens. >> Little PDSC.
Like whenever I see like cops, >> you can have you can
have a seat belt. >> Okay. Okay.
where
uh Washington or
>> I'm trying to figure out where where
>> it would be either.
>> Okay. So he pops
>> Oh, look at how experienced he is with uh doing this
out of his pocket. He he goes to say like the name of the place
where they're where I I guess someone else is from, right? He's
going to start talking about locations and he pauses the stream
there.
I've never touched a drug in my life. So, >> now if you
didn't hear that, that's Kerbine saying, "I've never touched
a drug in my life." H >> good luck picking that back up.
Give me a test,
>> They think we have drugs in the car,
Hey, is there any can I do like a test or anything? Is there
like anything? I I I promised all my life I've not never
>> They think there's drugs in the car. Hey, can can you
like search my car and then get me put me through a bunch of
tests? Hey, could you like could you like violate all of my rights
that I could have held if I just shut the up? Hey, would you
would you totally like my ass for no reason other than I would
like that is is essentially what he's saying. If if they have
a blood test, they will not have a blood test right >> Yeah.
Well, I know it can't be rapid, but like I I I promise I >> Sorry.
I've like been live streaming my whole day. If I was doing like
literally at any point I could like pull it up like I I've literally
just been like filming my whole time driving. I And I haven't
I haven't like
>> search me. Okay. Yes, 100%. You can check my fingers
even or something. My nose if you guys want. >> I just
need you to calm down, huh? >> Yes. Sorry. I turn around.
Turn around for me. push me behind back
>> like he's he's acting
I understand that he he seems like he's acting erratic. I feel
like this is because
the cops are there or sorry because he's got the stream on. I
do not think he would I do not think he'd be acting like this
if he didn't have the stream on. Okay. Not suspicious behavior
rising to cause.
I if they Hold on. No, no, no, no. He's not They don't need probable
cause. If he says, "Can you guys do a search or
Why do they need probable cause? He's letting them do it. Probable
cause is how they violate your rights and search your vehicle,
right?
You don't you don't need probable cause if he says, "Hey, could
you search my car or something?"
>> I'm not under. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's fine. It's fine. Fine.
>> My pallet's on my left for that. That's >> I'm
sorry guys that you guys are even feel that. So I know this is
like [__] huge bit of your time. Yeah. You want to
go through that or anything? I just got a new wallet. So [music]
check for like any like said powder on me or anything. I was
nose residue.
You check inside my shoes if you want. I can take off my shoes
if need be. I can take off this whatever.
Sorry. Thank you. >> Hold on. What was that when he uh
Thank >> Let's try to see what this is. >> Dude,
they
>> Oh, I thought we saw something here. Maybe not. >> Just
going through like everything in our car just to find
any anywhere.
>> Did he just sniff snort after saying check for nose
residue?
>> Uh yeah, I believe he did. And he's always had this
like sniffling problem. I don't know if he's got allergies or
what. He's always done this, right?
just always.
Oh, he's sitting in the cop car right now. Okay. I don't know
why we get this within the I guess this is Kerbopene like looking
through after they're searching, right? Oh, there he is in the
car, right?
Oh, no. That's not him. That's That is that him? That's got to
be a cop. That's front seat. That's front seat.
>> Oh god, dude. I'm shaking. I shouldn't be shaking because
it's not nothing to be scared about, but like >> holy man.
So, he suggested they search his car, which is a wild thing to
do. Even if you're even if you're innocent, it's a wild thing
to do, right, dude? Why are they searching? They think we have
cuz they saw a straw and they said they had it had white substances
in it.
I'm like, bro.
So, they're trying to find anything. They don't know, but it's
like nothing's coming back. So, they're just So, they're wasting
their time cuz there's nothing in there.
It's just frustrating. And I'm I'm worried that the longer this
goes, they're just trying to figure out.
I just don't know what's going on. I don't know why this is taking
I feel like they're literally I feel like there's making something
up so they can go through it. >> Dude, there's no way.
There's no way he's sitting in the cop car pulling his phone
out so he can like take so he can live stream them going through
his [__]
>> I like find something because of the because of the
>> Not that that's I don't think that's like illegal. I
don't know if that's explicitly prohibited in any way, but to
me, like you're just asking. There's certain behaviors you can
engage with with the cops where you could be like respectful
and understanding and not like add chance for them to to catch
you on something, right? I just I don't know. It's like it's
crazy to me that you would like try to get these you're like
doing a bunch of things to upset these cops. >> Warned
maybe.
Then relax if you're innocent. It's just it's nerve-wracking,
dude. I don't like I don't I don't know if like something just
gets me dude cops just do random randomly so I'm just worried
dude
>> you have to pee
uh we can stop at a gas station after
time I got to roll it up
I didn't know I didn't know you want I didn't off this I
>> all right you okay with running through some field soiety
test make sure >> yeah 100% yeah >> dude I
he all he yes all he had to do was not talk they had nothing
they would have just handed him a But he explicitly asked them
to like fist his for no
Like like for no reason at all.
And again, I I actually am probably leaning in everybody else's
direction that other than other than like reckless driving, a
ticket for reckless driving. I don't think he should get in trouble
at all. He did. No, figuratively. Not literally. I use literally
as figuratively. Okay. He But he's asking them to search his
car when they probably didn't have probable cause to search his
car. And then he's asking, "Can I do field sobriety tests?" Which,
by the way, there are times if you're just tired, you could fail
field sobriety tests,
right? Which
>> it can happen.
>> Is it going to be out of the car? >> Okay. Let
me just like stretch out a little bit cuz I guess I'm a little
said after he start putting his hand back out a little shook
him up. And then
>> also the progression is
>> Yeah. just step to the front of my car if you want to
stretch or whatever you want to do. >> Yeah, I appreciate
that. Thank you. >> Oh my god.
>> Okay. Don't need to do anything.
>> All right. I just want you to stand right there. >> Face
back towards me. >> Uh face back towards you.
>> Oh, I think about my back towards you. >> All right.
Put your feet together. Heal heel to zero. Keep your arms down
by your side. >> Do you wear [clears throat] Do you have
any medical conditions? >> Just ADHD.
>> Yeah. Do you wear glasses or contacts? >> I wear
contacts. contacts. Do you have them in right now? >> Yes,
sir. >> What kind of contacts are they? >> Uh, like
the >> soft or hard?
>> Is there a difference? >> Yeah. One of them's
glass, one of them >> Soft. You see my pin? >> Follow
up with your eyes and your eyes
>> Don't move your head.
>> Just follow it up now. Okay.
The advisor traffic stop.
>> All right.
>> You got sorry again. ADHD and I'm also a little shaken
up. >> I got you. >> Just stand right there. >> Yes,
sir.
>> Feet together, heel to heel, toe to toe. Arms down by
your side. Yep. >> I want you to imagine a line coming
out of your left foot. I want you to place your right foot in
front of your left foot. Heel to toe. >> Left foot heel
toe. Right foot left. >> This is the This is the tough
one. Okay. >> Heel toe. >> If you're if you're like
exhausted, I can see yourself I could see you losing >> Don't
move from that position until I tell you to and do not begin
the test until I tell you to. You understand? >> All right.
For this test, you're going to take nine heel to toe steps straight
down that imaginary line. On the ninth step, you're going to
leave your lead foot planted. Take a series of small steps to
turn around and take nine more heel to toe steps back down that
line. >> Okay. I'm going to demonstrate it for >> Oh,
yeah. So say [laughter] >> right foot in front of your
left foot heel up. >> One, two, >> two, three. So
on a nine. Leave your lead foot planted. Take a serious small
steps. Turn around. One, two, three. So on back down to nine.
>> I took three steps, but you're going to take nine steps.
>> Okay. During this test, you're going to watch your feet
while you perform the test. Verbally count out loud each step
you take. Keep your arms down by your side. Keep your arms down
by your side. And once you begin the test, do not stop the test.
Do you understand? I >> All right. You can begin.
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 Oh,
>> eight nine. Lead.
I believe the lead. Right. So, right here.
>> 1 2 3 4 5 6
8 9. >> For this next test, I'm going to have you just
stand on the feet together. Heel heel toe toe. Arms down by side.
Don't begin your test until I tell you once, man. Okay, >> this
is
>> okay. As much as it sounded a little bit like he might
have [__] up like uh what at seven there. It seems
like the cop's going to keep running them through them that this
shouldn't be a fail yet. >> Going to be the one leg stand.
You're going to take whichever foot you choose. You're going
to raise it approximately 6 in off the ground, keeping your foot
parallel to the ground. Going to count in the manner of 10,00
1, 1,002, 100,00 so on until I tell you to stop. Okay? >> Okay.
I'm going to demonstrate this.
I'm use my right foot so you can use before you cheat. Okay.
>> No, I do not. Hold on. [clears throat] >> I do
not believe Darius is actually impaired for this. By the way,
guys, I do not think
>> it's not a pass fail. They always say. Okay. Well, I
I don't think he's impaired for this. So, even if he's it up,
it's not because he's impaired. >> Watch your foot. >> Like
this. 10003. >> Watch your foot. Uh 1004 1005 1006 107
2008 1009 2010 1234
2018 19201223
240 125 2002628
sorry 7282930
apologize Shaky flip. >> Oh, he failed the count to 30
test. God >> Okay. All right. This test is going to be
similar to the first test. Okay. I'm going to have you follow
the tip of my with your eyes and your eyes only. >> I'm
going to make a couple small circles around your face. I'm going
to come in close to your nose, but I'm not going to touch you.
>> I just want you to follow tip hands. There you go. >> Just
want you to stand with your feet together, heel, heel, toe to
toe. Follow tip with your eyes and your eyes. Okay.
You see it? >> Yep. So this test, for this next test, I
just have you stand once again with your feet together, heel
to heel to heel, toe toe, arms by your side. This one is very
simple. Okay. I'm going to have you tilt your head back slightly.
Not yet. Tilt your head back slightly. Close your eyes. When
you believe 30 seconds has passed, open your eyes. Tell me to
stop. >> Okay. You understand? >> All right. Just
tilt your head back slightly. Close your eyes. Begin.
>> Okay. How long do you think that was? >> 30 seconds.
>> Yeah. Around there. kind of I went fast to start and
I kind of slowed it down.
>> uh, how did you get there? >> Uh, how'd I get
there? Just one, two, >> Pound your head like that.
>> All right. So, for this next step, I'm going to be seen
right here and face back towards my car. >> Okay. Like
this.
>> All right.
Go have a seat right there in my passenger seat for me. >> Okay.
Thank you.
>> Oh jeez.
>> Do the cops realize he's streaming or nah? I mean, it
looks like the phone's in his pocket to me. It sounds like the
phone's in his pocket. I don't know if you could argue that they
think he's streaming here.
>> I don't think so.
>> They are trying to get me, bro. Bro, they are like pulling
the me. They [snorts] went through the whole car. Now they have
me doing every sobriety test
bro. Failed.
Oh my god, dude. I'm like PTSD,
dude. Oh, dude. I'm sweating bullets, man. Like, I Why am I sweating
so bad? I don't know. >> I don't think Yeah, I I'm never
going to argue that this is illegal like to for him to record.
Like it's I believe he has all of his rights until he is under
arrest, right? It's just about how cooperative you want to be
with the cops. The cops are going to knock you down. If they
if he seemed cooperative before this, if he's been streaming
the whole thing and didn't tell them, they're going to knock
him down to like negative 100 points on coop on how much he's
cooperating. Right. >> I [clears throat] got a couple.
>> Again, it's not about legality. It's about how the cops
like like how the cops see you. Cops can like make your life
hard if you've done nothing wrong. They absolutely can. You don't
understand that, you're stupid, okay? And you're going to keep
getting in trouble with cops. They'll make your they don't make
your life incredibly difficult.
So, doing [__] like this, like like recording the
whole time and not telling them that that can be something you
could do, but I wouldn't do it. I especially wouldn't do it in
a way where I keep removing the recording device and talking
to it so that if they ever look at the the camera from inside
the car, it's going to be obvious that you were doing it. full
buzz balls earlier. I do not have any buzz balls.
>> Did you know you can revoke consent to search at any
time? I don't know my rights. Why didn't you tell the cops to
search a car? Cuz there there's nothing for us to We're not hiding
anything.
I'm just like wigged out. I don't like that I'm so wigged out,
Come back. Can we Why am I still in the passenger seat of this
car? Can I please get out, dude? Okay.
[clears throat] So,
improper charges, improper passing technique, DUI, drive under
the influence of any other intoxicating substance, and possession
of paraphernalia. So, I'm guessing he had a pipe or something
to do drugs with in his car that they found during the search.
Quick throwback to the Yeah, I I know. You want me to pop this
up? Hold on a second.
Asking the guy if he's Haitian. What a great sign. >> I
don't know what he is, to be honest. Well, he's an American.
Wait, is this a different view of this? >> Can uh can't
be a cop without blood. >> Anyway, yeah, they you did ask
is the guy Haitian? Is he Haitian? You a Haitian, bro? I went
through this VOD and saw you were curious if there was more to
in Biscuit Fuel Mike VOD. I got six minute clip of them hanging
out earlier. Okay, give me a second. Let me look at this real
quick. I'll grab that. We'll just see. Okay. Uh I'll check this
out in just a little bit. We'll see if we go back to it. Okay.
Now, from here, the after after this all happened, Darius does
get arrested. I believe he likely spent the night in jail, but
I'm not 100% sure.
And then we had the Discord logs after the fact. So, Kerbine,
the girl who was with him, goes to Discord, starts talking about
it. All right, cops are
What happened? 12-year-old
happened. So, apparently one of the cops looked young. All right,
they're impounding the car. No shot.
Uh, I have to take the dogs and buy a hotel and he probably can't
get his car cuz he probably needs a physical ID.
Uh, did they breath test him? Yes, but the 12-year-old cop had
an ego and wanted to say he's a drug addict. They kept asking
me how long he's done.
They said drug tests take months. That is not true. They were
just trying to get They thought I think they thought they could
get Darius to admit to taking drugs and so they probably just
said whatever they had to to get Darius to keep talking, right?
and to not let them go say, "Hey, are we under arrest?" This
is where knowing your rights probably helps, right? You just
say like, "Am I under arrest for something? Like, give me my
ticket, but if I'm under arrest, please say so."
You say it in a respectful way. Probably better than that. Anyway,
so these were the original logs that came out. This is all funny,
but uh then I got taped to go grab me the full logs here. I shouldn't
even say that, but impounding the car.
So, hold on. Uh, they told me I can't get out of the car to talk.
Pray for him. No, he's fine. He legit just didn't get in the
left lane. Cops are I mean, Darius is for passing like speeding
past them in the right lane. 12-year-old
happened. He's in jail cuz he's under the influence. They're
impounding the car. This we read all of these.
Uh, he got pulled over and walked to and they walked to him in
driver's seat. Lol. There's no troll. I'm in the hotel with dogs.
Closest airport is three hours away. Yes, I yelled at them. I
yelled at the cops when they said they'll put them in a pound.
Oh, can't hear from him until 8 a.m. It was the skinny white
12-year-old cop dealing with Darius that arrested him. The cop
was a That cop was Don't think I'm making it to my friends for
Halloween hotel. Yes, next to jail. I canceled my flight to drive
with him.
Uh, they thought he was coked out. 12-year-old was embarrassed.
He pulled over someone who he was sure was a degenerate and wanted
to pin something on him.
Uh, I don't doubt this really. It seems like they were fishing
from the beginning, right?
Like he it was it was a combination of he was acting in a weird
way and they had no evidence. It was just that he was like acting
in a weird way. Why is passing in the right lane illegal? I literally
do that every day in a semi. Uh, Trucker Joe, without slowing
down. Without slowing down and without switching to the other
lane, you pass cops. I'm pretty sure you're not allowed to do
that. I'm pretty sure every single
I've driven on American freeways like the the tollways and stuff
and I'm positive that okay there might be some states where you
can do that truck or Joe or maybe trucks can do it. I don't know.
I I'm telling you I see signs every single time I get on a freeway
that say hey
uh lane switch or slow down
Yeah, I don't I don't think that's true. Trucker Joe,
it's highly state specific. Yeah, but Trucker Joe's got to go
all over the
Trucker Joe's a little truck driver, so I don't know. Anyway,
hold on. Yeah, sorry. It's not It's literally not passing on
the right. It's uh the cop. Yeah, the cop was on the shoulder.
Oh, maybe the way I said it, Trucker Joe, you didn't hear it
or or I I might maybe illustrated it wrong with the thing I said.
Yes, the cops are in the shoulder. They had somebody pulled over
and Darius did not switch lanes and he did not slow down. He
just blew past them. Yeah. So, they were they had somebody stopped
in the shoulder and there were two cop cars. So, one of the cops
got in their cop car and like drove him down and and gave him
a Well, I assume they were going to give him a ticket, but then
it turned into a misdemeanor. Yep.
He did it after finding white powder arresting trying to pin
Darius or pin something on Darius. Before checking anything,
they came up and asked me how long he's done. So, they were already
trying to pin him for drugs. He sounded like he was a meth head
when he first started talking to them. He was like tweaking out.
Some of that is stress. Some of that is acting for the camera.
I tried. They yelled at me to get back in the car. I guess he
gave them consent to search the car. I didn't hear they made
the me stand outside with the dogs. It was so cold. Listen, if
I wanted to leave, I can. It's more about the responsibility
of the dogs and the ID. Then she posts the picture of GMO and
the other dog and then the cops searching the car. Here's your
pick. It's the Coke. I'm kidding. Okay. Somebody asked her what's
on the street probably. I don't have the messages around this.
We're just going to scroll through these real quick. Wasn't even
talking to them. It was Darius who gave them consent. Then they
went crazy on my suitcase after finding the white powder on a
straw. They to Oh, well, hold on. Wait, was Kerbafine doing Coke?
They went crazy on my suitcase after finding the white powder
on a straw. What the [__] White powder was on a
Wait, what was somebody doing? Coke in this car?
Hold on. I'm guessing
pixie sticks.
Maybe pixie. Maybe
she said she'd never touched drugs in her life. Okay. Well,
I mean, it's Darius's. It I don't even know whose car it is.
Never mind. I We'll We'll look into it more after. Okay. We're
going to watch Darius went live. So, we're going to go watch
some of his VOD, I think.
So, they told me that he has a history of violent drug usage
when running a background check on his ID, which of course I
thought was BS cuz I know what would come up if they ran a background
Uh, I told the cops it was probably protein powder and they laughed
at me. Took it for evidence to test. said it takes months to
find out. They said blood tests also take months to see if he's
clean. I don't think any of this is true. They took his blood,
I was told, at a hotel nearby. He can get out, but it won't be
proven innocent for months.
There's the dogs in the hotel.
They know nothing. Jimmo's bit me twice because he never trained
her. [laughter]
Oh,
Kerbene likes the the puppy more than Jimmo cuz Jimmo is like
old and wild now from never being trained. That sucks. Jima is
such a cute dog. These are like the cutest dogs in the world.
Jim's like the cutest dog in the world. It's crazy. Sucks. They've
never trained them. Chi-Chi has bit me zero times.
Coordinated with Prawn. They did not ask me once if I was on
drugs. At least three times. Closer to five to six. Bro, they
wouldn't let me go over with him, so I have no idea. I have a
few contacts. I have few a few contacts right now. Then I'll
tell him about uh that I'll tell him about when it's out when
he's out. Yes, but he's going to have to do it. I don't know
what this is
Uh, cops ruin my flowers or sorry, thought it would be a ticket.
Cops ruined my flowers. That's when he was telling me that they
think he's on drugs. When they first were talking to him, he
was fine. When he stepped out of the car, but then when when
they walked away, I don't know what happened. Well, I'm not going
to talk about the situation right now, but the cop, those cops
are a bunch of losers. What do you mean you're not going to talk
about She just talked a ton about the situation. What do you
mean you're not going to talk about the situation right now?
You've been talking about the situation. Huh? What?
Pardon?
Okay. Anyway,
we keep looking.
Let's see here. We're going from this now. We've got the Darius
VOD. I think I Yeah, I went through both of these.
And
I've got a Prawn Vod that he was on as well, but I think Riyle
was telling me the Darius VOD's way better.
Oh, maybe not. Hold on. This is a good part of the the Prawn
VOD. So, this is first. He He gets on Princess's stream for a
little bit. >> You got a DUI? I know, right? I wasn't under
any influence, too. It's so stupid. I've got a blood test. I
can't wait for it to come back.
>> Yeah, we'll check it out. Neos.
>> Okay. Can you stretch it out now?
>> It's going to fall out. >> Well, hold it, dude.
Hold it, dumbass. >> It's I think it's in there. >> I'm
trying to see. Did it pop out?
>> Now you almost got it.
Thank God I did not. >> No. What?
>> Oh yeah. I'm mostly just worried about it healing. If
I was in there,
>> they were trying to keep me there till next Thursday.
Brody
been filled out if that's the case. >> I'm like debating
if I just give up and like I we can we hang out here or what?
Breathalyzer. I I didn't I wasn't drunk. I Nothing came up. I
didn't drink it. >> Yeah, that's why you should have asked
for the breathalyzer, bro. You should have asked for the breathalyzer.
>> Zero. Oh, that's their wish. Dude, I wish I wasn't trying
to be respectful and not put a camera in their face. I should
have put a camera in their face that whole time. That was insane.
That was the most insane situation I've ever been in my life.
They thought I was on coach because I was talking back because
I was nervous. And then
uh they started telling they started telling Kirby I had a history
of hard drug usage.
>> Do we hate cops yet? I think >> I talk about the
drug expert they had on
What you >> talking about? The drug expert they had on
staff that look
>> They have this like kid who look looks like 19 like
looks like straight out of college and he's like oh I'm I'm a
drug expert. I'm an expert on drugs. I can tell he's on
[laughter] I can tell >> and many cases like this and it's
like >> many cases like what >> seems like false
allegations >> like being ner being a black guy getting
>> of you just saying oh of you trying to literally get
someone to say that oh do they think we don't know each other?
>> Dude be careful. You really got to learn how to talk
to cops, brother. >> Okay. I do that first so I can get
like >> You really got to learn how to talk to cops, brother.
>> You
talk to cops cuz you don't talk at all apparently. >> Don't
be complaining. >> I don't dude. What are you doing? You're
so close. >> Glad you're free, buddy.
>> Glad you're free, buddy. >> Okay. I don't want
to watch this anymore. Gh. Okay. Okay. All right. We go to the
Darius spot, I think. Go to the Darius Sod here. We'll just listen
to Darius talk about it. Okay. >> Already touching those.
I'm digging in it, dude. I saw you boofing it while driving,
bro. You ain't fooling us. Okay, you're the gay one for seeing
that.
And also, why didn't they check my They made me get booty butt
naked. >> Do they? >> They still have double TTS/
alerts. I think that's fairly new that the double TTS alerts
were on. And that's on Pro stream as well. >> You watch
them do that or just >> No, never. They made me get fully
naked like they saw. And I was soft, by the way. So >> I
would hope you you were soft. >> I was soft. So but the
[__] on my
>> How many dicks did you have to suck? >> Zero.
Everyone was too old and shriveled up.
I tried to get in the showers. I was like, "Let me in the showers."
They didn't let me. They wanted to see that
>> Is okay. It's on the name. But once the test comes back
clean, won't the charges get dropped?
>> Months from now. >> So you're telling me I have
drug charges on me for the next 6 months?
No, cuz I mean your trial is uh >> because you're tripping
the out. Okay, I understand on stream I was I I literally ended
stream turn it on and I was trolling that I was tripping out
while they weren't in the car. When I talked to the guy at the
start, I was relatively chill. I even I dead ass like pretty
much asked him to to suck his burn points.
Okay. How does he not understand that? Like that offering to
do everything the cops want to just be like I I'm not I'm clean.
I'm clean. I got to go. I got to go. I'm clean. I'm clean. I
swear to God I'm clean. That that seems suspicious to cops. It's
mostly about the perception. Wait, why is this up? Okay, come
on,
>> I think cops I don't know why cellular is better there.
>> Okay, here we go. Here we go. >> Okay. I don't
know why I don't know why cell is better there. >> Cellular
is always better.
>> Uh, actually, you're right. Uh, sir, >> bet the
cops bugged your There was some mysterious weed pen in my backpack.
I've literally never seen this weed pen >> I put it in
your backpack cuz they put it on the roof of your car. >> Yeah.
Well, she put this weed backpack that was this weed pen that
was on the roof of my car >> into my backpack. I don't
It's a mysterious weed pen. Never seen it before. Beat the case.
I literally will beat this case. But >> like I I do believe
that Darius would just have a weed pen sitting somewhere in his
car that would get grabbed. That's why he should never agree
to a search, right? Cuz of course Darius and his friends at definitely
somebody's been drunk and passed out back there and dropped their
weed pen on the floor or something. Why would you ever accept
a search like that? Why would you ever offer it? >> But
guess what guys? Here's the situation. We are in a financial
we are in a financial like you had weed. I didn't even have weed.
They didn't even give me for weed. What? They didn't even give
me for that pen. I don't think Here's the thing. That pen I I
think. Did you finish? >> Do you want me to try? >> Oh,
you can do whatever you want. Queen.
Boost Mobile. Not doing any favors. I'm on Boost Mobile. Broke
ass.
Weird. Weed
Operation. Please lay low for 6 months. Dude, you can't just
lay low. Dude, what did I even do there?
Wait, we >> How does he not He knows what he did there
wrong, right? To get pulled over. >> You're at a financial
point where now we need your help as an audience member. We need
you guys posting this stream in other chats. We need you guys
engaging in chat paraphernalia.
We need we need we need chat activity. Listen, if you want to
call me a you want to say my ex-girlfriend got off [__]
I don't care. We just need more spam in the chat cuz here's the
thing. We are now dealing with about $16,000 in lawyer fees.
I have to get a lawyer for my ex because I think my case is just
going to keep on getting moved until my court appointed has free
time. And it's $6,000
for me to get rid of all this stuff. And I'm going to be honest,
I have to get rid of this drug stuff cuz there's no way I'm having
a DUI on my record. But especially, listen, I would love a DUI
on my record if I was actually intoxicated on anything. But I
was
intoxicated even a little bit.
>> Uh, Portoell, you missed it. That's because that's what
he was charged with, possession of paraphernalia.
Like he he definitely asked like, "What is paraphernalia?" I
don't know what that means because it's one of the charges he
was given.
>> 16K. All viewers need to obtain a job. Zeus was actually
sad. You were arrested. He freaked out. He was going to come
bail you out. No, he wasn't. Zeus just likes to be performative.
He wasn't going to do >> and he couldn't bail him out.
He had no >> Zeus was actually I don't I don't trust that.
But we just been blowing money the past 4 months. That has nothing
to do with the situation. Uh, okay. Ry, if you've still got from
a couple weeks ago that stream of him going over all of his expenses
from the trip to Canada with Hannah, I think this is a great
time to pull that up. [laughter] Somebody has He's been blowing
money. He's like, "What? No. No. If I literally spent all that
money I I Here's a choice. I two choices. One, I spent money
on doing things I enjoy spend or spend money on lawyer fees.
Uh, I'd prefer the sec the first one. >> Why? Why
does he realize he just said something nearly as like I have
my choice. Okay, it's a choice of mine to spend my money on my
taxes or to do the things I like and I just chose not to pay
my taxes. That's I like doing things I like.
The first op the first one is not optional. What are you doing?
But now I'm at the point where I need to make money for lawyers
because here's what my life's going to look like. Monthly lawyer
fees. I'm going to start paying. I'm going to try to pay half
of everything, which is going to be like $10,000, which is all
my money. Uh >> supposed to be a vampire >> and then
I'm going to be spending like 2,000 a month for the next like
6 or 7 months paying everything up. He said he up and left you
that he felt bad.
Okay, so here's Benzino. Here's something I want you guys to
realize about Zeus. Zeus is 18 of the reason why I'm in this
situation. Because Zeus made charges that I did burglary and
also criminal mischief.
I am now being profiled. What happened in that car? I didn't
stream it unfortunately, but >> I You know, there's a really
easy way to not get like a ton of profiling done based on their
your background check. Cuz that is almost certainly what it was,
right? They looked at his background check and go, "Oh, this
guy's like a massive loser. He's got all these all these charges
in the past year." Like, oh, okay, [__] this guy.
But you just don't do the crimes. Don't do the crimes. Stop breaking
the law. But that guy was chill as with me until he pulled up
my record. After he pulled up my record, he would start saying
like, "Oh, I have a criminal history of doing coke, of doing
drugs." He said,
>> he he just he just started straight up lying." The dude
the dude went up to her and she said, "Oh, you didn't know about
>> Darius put all of these years into becoming like a functional
alcoholic and they don't even get his drug of choice correct."
How up is that? Okay. How [__] up is that? This guy
drinks himself into a stouper like half of the time he streams.
Gets himself into all kinds of trouble and they don't even get
the drug right. >> Violent pass with drugs. I'm like, "What
the fuck?"
>> I said he doesn't have one and they said, "Well, he's
lying to you." >> They said you don't know him clearly.
>> They literally Why didn't Why didn't you just say I've
literally l I literally looked at his uh background check like
yesterday. Like he his his crimes are like known. I know his
crimes. Why would you say you don't know him? That sounds like
cope. You don't know him. You don't really know him. Yeah, that
sounds like total cope. Just say, "I've literally looked at his
background check. He's been open about his legal troubles. I
can look it up. We can all look it up. That it happened in states
where you could just look this up. I know that it's in Flugerville.
I know it's in Texas, right? I know all this stuff. I That's
widely known, by the way. I didn't just say something crazy."
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Why did you turn black? I turned trailer trash. It's
different. >> It's It's all those people's fault. Like
genuinely, why I'm getting profiled right now and why my life
is getting progressively worse. This is literally what the legal
system does. They once you once you have a record, every they
they get on your ass cuz you're an easy pickings. You're like
a cow that has infinite meat. They now I have now supplied meat
to multiple counties. >> You're you're giving us milk.
Yeah. He
He's so close to describing what's going on here. He's like right
there. He's right right there. [laughter]
He has quiet dad. He is right there. He's so close. He's so close.
Dude, this is crazy. Uh, also guys, I'm going to head over to
kick only for the rest of the stream. All right, kick only for
the rest of the stream. I think we have we have donos rolling
over from yesterday as well. So, go ahead, donate, sub if you
want to have more time to this stream. We're going to go for
a long one tonight. Okay.
Okay. Ending on Twitch. Love you guys. Put somebody throw the
kick link in the Twitch chat if you can. And I'm going to end
on Twitch and head over to kick only.
I'm going to give them like a minute to switch over, guys, so
we don't leave them behind with the Darius content as we finish
it up. All right.
For here, this one.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Milk, you say? Yes. He's a He's a lullcow,
unfortunately for him. Okay.
I I like the I like the content, though. You are not getting
profiled. You literally are a perfect example of why profiling
is such a useful tool for police. [laughter]
It turns out when you assume Darius is committing a crime. You
just happen to be correct a lot of the time. And it has nothing
to do with race. >> If they're lying, you should sue them.
You I don't think you can lie. You can't sue some a cop for lying
cuz they're allowed to do anything they can. They're allowed
to say whatever they want to try to get you to admit to doing
something that they think they have probable cause for. You done?
>> You do one more. >> Do one more for the road.
Yeah. >> Okay. Um, >> get crazy.
>> Your nose is caked in. I literally have
>> Is Darius even black? He looks white to me. Uh, I will
say, all right,
for this arrest in Oklahoma, they put his race down as black
only. Not mixed, not Indian, not white, but black only. As his
criminal record has grown, for some reason, they start putting
him in the category of black instead of white. Okay, I'm not
going to make any comment on that. That might be some profiling.
All right. >> I I think I did coke during San Diego. That's
it. >> Why are you Why would you even admit that on live?
Like, what's wrong with you? I think I did allegedly, but like
I haven't done Coke. >> Allegedly. You are claiming yourself.
You can't say allegedly when it's
>> I haven't done Coke in any
>> This is just who he is on stream, by the way. He does
this stuff. He He is not
>> Darius is not stupid enough that he doesn't know that
this is like a bit that he's doing right now. Okay. But he does
this when he's on stream with the cops, literally, and then wonders
why they think he's acting erratically.
Right. Haven't done in any capacity and
>> That's for sure. That's a fact.
>> It's an illegal drug. >> You were driving while
black. They even put me black on the thing. >> They did.
>> They wanted me to be a statistic.
They put down black to get me.
And this is why we're here.
>> Grace Dorp. Somehow they somehow he keeps leaving out
the fact that he had already broken the law. They can't make
you a statistic when the first thing they pull you over for is
literally like a a misdemeanor. Like it's an actual
>> Gracep was a little bit of the downfall of me.
>> Hold on. Got read that. >> Read that chat again.
Grey Stor was a little bit of the downfall of me being a normal
guy. Legally black. Let's go.
>> You did not get profiled. Gift luck. Hey, you stupid
balding.
>> I unironically got profiled because of my profile. They
saw my as soon as they saw my criminal history. The dude kept
asking me, "So, what's your warrant for?" And I was like, "Uh,
it's a violation protected." That's not profiling, by the way.
Or at least I don't I don't think that's profiling. Profiling
is like looking at visible indicators and then deciding something
about someone, right? Maybe, maybe. Oh, that's at least what
people mean when they say profiling, right? Like racial
like this kind of profiling. That's the That's the purpose. Okay.
You don't want to You don't want to be around somebody capable
of violence and have no idea >> order. Uh yeah. And then
he'd call Austin to see if they're going to take me. Austin didn't
want to take me.
So, because I'm dealing with it, as I've already told you guys,
by the way,
um Austin didn't want to take me. So, he
uh just started saying like he started keep asking me like, "Yeah,
so what are these charges for? I can't really see what they're
for." I'm like, "Violation protective order pretty much. It's
just I got a protective order with my ex-girlfriend a couple
months back and I've been having a lot of troubles with it. My
lawyers have been usually dealing with it." And then he walks
up after that to Kirby and ask when I started taking I'm like,
"Are you serious?" >> He had an open warrant and thinks
that's profiling. Yeah, he does have an open warrant in um in
Austin as well, which is, you know, it is what it is there. I
think that's the Merc, right? M I think Murk was in a chat taunting
him about it. Maybe his maybe his own chat. I can't remember.
She was just taunting him about it, too. >> Are you serious?
>> I beat my ex.
When did I ever get >> Yeah, this is like reckless driving.
>> he actually in Oklahoma, you know, he's gotten a lot
of compliments on the pair. >> They call me Justin Bieber.
>> They called him the bad boy Justin
He's the evil Justin Bieber. >> Also, I did. You guys see
my weight on >> I'm sure in Oklahoma they consider that
a compliment. Yes. You look like Justin Bieber, bro. That's That's
them being comp complimentary. Okay. All right. Yeah, we listen.
He's had he's been holding some L's recently. We let him hold
that one. Okay. It's possible [clears throat] they meant it.
It's possible they meant it.
>> The criminal rap sheep. >> Did they show it? >> Uh,
I don't know. But they definitely I saw it for a little bit.
>> Prime guessed you were 160. I didn't believe it. >> He
guessed 160. >> Yeah, I didn't believe that. >> How
much do you think I am? >> I think you're over 160.
>> All you want to say? Um, I just think uh like if you
do work out consistently, muscle weighs more than she's not even
gonna say what she thinks. >> Muscle weighs more than fat.
Um, >> I'm like 190.
>> I was going to guess actually
180, I think. >> I'm like 190. >> Yeah. So, I think
I was going to guess >> Like 190, which is bad. I'm like,
if I wasn't so jacked, I'd be morbidly obese. >> Well,
muscle weighs more than fat. That was the whole point. So, like
you could be jacked as weigh 190 and you would be very confident
and happy with yourself.
>> JB, I listen.
I know you don't know the whole history here, okay? But this
is not boring. I I understand how you could think that and I
haven't done the best job building this up. Usually, I build
the Darius stories the Darius stories up a little bit more, but
you haven't been with us every step of the way, okay? You have
to think of this as investment to get to know Darius for all
the content he's going to provide in the future. Okay? This is
This is always good content forever.
Just invest now. Trust me. Pay attention. All right? Because
the best part of doing Darius content is watching him say all
of the things he's going to do, all the things he's going to
stop doing, and then watch all of those things reverse, and he
just does it all again. Okay. >> No, I don't think so.
I I don't like
>> But you you wanted to be a meatthead for a second.
>> you want to do like steroids? >> I do when I'm
32.
Why is she leaking this? Why is she [laughter] Dude, he just
thought the exact same thing. Hold on. >> You You wanted
to be a meatthead for a
>> there's a little eye dart over like there's no way she's
going to like the
>> Steroids illegal. Illegal.
Are those also [clears throat] illegal drugs? >> Steroids
are very
>> I I caught him at some point. His eyes have closed.
But >> that's what I'm saying. I want to uh >> You
don't look 190. Does that help? I hope you're >> People
always say [__] like that. I hate [laughter] it.
>> Dude, the bloatia stuff got to him so badly. Like so
so so badly. >> Yeah. 190 of muscles. >> I hope I
don't know if Tape Deck is watching. I hope you know that you
broke this guy's brain completely.
The Blossius IRL stuff that it it like broke his brain entirely.
Tape's got a lot of victims. It's not great.
That's I just I immediately identified that if I wanted to fight
with tape deck, I would just lose. I was like, you you don't
fight with the people who sit there making memes and like mocking
people for fun and are funny and everyone thinks they're funny.
This was a D Masterson's advice. That's sick Boy's fault. It
is actually Sick Boy's fault, too. Um
D Masterson gave this advice to Vita once and I just decided
to follow it. It's like if you have people in your audience who
are funny, they do memes and stuff, never pick fights with them.
It's just never going to work. It's like not a good strategy.
You're going to try to do your content and they're just going
to sit there thinking of ways to be funny mocking you. Okay.
It's just dangerous. It's a dangerous game to play and many people
attempt it.
>> Doesn't work out well. >> Yeah, I know. That's
why I said it's like I'm like definitely like 23 24% body fat.
>> Sick boy is also why I'm bulking. I literally did I
did I did
I did say I am bulking. So I am bulking. >> Dude, the contacts
remind Why is everyone talking about the contact? The context
was because I first of all I it was for cosplay. Second of all,
no, I just opened it. >> Second of all, I we were going
to go out to a bar, so I was doing like a vampire look cuz I
had the contacts.
He has 200 for sure. God damn. >> That guy's name is Jason
Kunar arc. So, he's obviously a
he only [laughter] knows either fat woman or childlike bodies.
>> Well, if he knows fat woman >> No, I'm saying
it's fat woman. Anyone that's not a childlike body is a fat one
of them.
>> He's a >> curious. Why you give her a hickey?
Did I do that? >> Well, this is a vampire bites.
>> A vampire bit me. [laughter] >> Steroids fix life
and they will fix
said he was extra angry cuz he was >> They did fix They
did fix >> extra Emily's cousin. >> Darius's Sorry.
Misg's life. >> No. What?
>> Because of the extra. >> Uhhuh. Girls 1.5.
You think I'm scared? >> Okay. Are you ready? >> No.
I just opened this. You keep ask You told me to go get another
and then you >> I thought you were done. Bro, Darius is
angry enough.
Uh I definitely am like a really nice guy. >> You can't
do steroids. I think you will literally get in. You will >> Darius
Darius literally can't control his anger without steroids and
he builds muscle just fine. I don't know why he would ever do
steroids. It's actually >> in jail for years if you get
steroids. Um, with your with your personality and your
who you are, you should not be on >> No, I shouldn't be
on.
>> This person's like the most transparent. This keropene
person is the most transer transparent readable person in the
world. Like she says something and she immediately notices like
how much it throws him off and then she tries to like work it
backwards. She's like trying not to upset him right now while
still having a conversation with your
i.e. rage issues. You'd be in jail forever, but she doesn't want
to say you have anger problems. >> Um, you told me that
like sometimes you need the release and that's why at like the
San Diego TwitchCon like you got in those fights. You should
not be on >> I didn't get into a fight cuz I wanted to
release. >> Uh, you said like you were down with anything.
Yeah. See, that's the problem. You were saying it feels good.
>> Like you don't lose. I felt good. I like >> get
get into fighting. Uh, competitive. That's fine. No, I just want
to look for easy targets in the street like a like a jackal
and then go for them.
Go for the Eddie Guru. >> Um, yeah. I wonder why the cops
profile people. I wonder why profiling happens. I wonder I wonder
when they look at your criminal history why they might go, "Oh,
this guy's got to go." >> Build. Dude, that guy is crazy
build. I was actually thinking I'm built like him. I should do
that. But that's like steroids. No, the steroids will chill you
out, king. Like ADHD.
>> Maybe I actually need Aderall. So here's So here's our
New Year's resolution.
One, we got to get uh Adderall cuz apparently our normal actions
are causing us to make people think we're on
Uh they don't know that I'm a niche internet micro celebrity.
And because of that, people think >> Your Bond Your Bondsman
really liked that, by the way. When I filled that out, she was
she was really excited. She actually wants us to shout her out
>> You can give her a card. >> Um I'll [laughter]
>> Oh, you're a famous criminal. Yeah. Get my name out
there. Get the word out. Famous criminals. I I love famous
>> Do you want me to shout her out now or after the case?
>> Probably after. >> Yeah. Uh >> cuz people
were calling the jail cell. >> Were they?
>> That's just effective marketing. They were trolling.
Like they were >> That's crazy that they that people were
trolling cuz they told me everything >> that someone literally
called and said, "Can you tell Darius bone her called?" And they're
like, "Do you know bone her?" And I was like, "Oh, no."
>> They [laughter] they just like were just very honest,
straightforward. Great people. They were great people to me.
>> One of their names was was a Maris something. I was
like, "Dude, what?" >> Great people to me. Every time I
called
>> Oh, she has she stopped all the the cops. great people
to be. Okay.
>> no, they post his mug shop probably in >> she's
been focused on the one cop. Yeah, they posted my mugshot. No
one I asked her. I was like, "Oh, is this mugshot going to be
online?" And she said, "Yeah, in like 2 weeks it'll be on like
the Atlas Daily or something." And I was like, "Uh,
okay."
The craziest is when I first called and she knew who she knew
who I was. She was like, "Yeah, he told me you would call." And
I was like, "What?" I like, "Was it the cops or was it >> No,
I was talking to me and her sit down cuz I told her I need a
counselor." >> Uh, Warp Thing, that is Zena's first >> I
was like tweaking. >> Yeah. So, she was like, "Yeah, no,
he told me he would call >> because that dude that dude
has picked me off. He tried to lecture me and he was like, "Yeah,
man." You know, I was like, cuz I started a conversation with
him. I was like, "Yeah, man. I'm Cuz I calmed down after he decided
to just arrest me cuz I was like, that's why I was freaking out
cuz I'm like, "Are you going to arrest me or not, man? I don't
like I have ADHD. I need to know what's happening right then
and there or I'm getting [__] >> That's why
I kept trying to get out of the car too and like at least be
in the surrounding situation. I don't have to talk to them. I
just need to know what the happening. It's your dogs. It's your
>> You guys are all talking behind me. Like it's like all
them are talking behind me and they're all doing weird [__]
They keep mentioning my legal stuff. I'm like dude you guys are
annoying as he turned himself into Austin as part of a problem.
Like no uh that's not part of the problem. I know everything
again. That was the >> This is why Ebert needs to get banned.
Ban Ben Eert. That's what I just hate these losers that sit there.
>> He was, by the way,
list less than 15 minutes ago, he was talking about how he needed
more chatters. He needed more activity. They need to get the
stream numbers up cuz he's got legal bills to pay. And now he's
like, "Ban, this Ebert guy, this Ebert guy is talking [__]
right now." >> He's a hardcore Julie Stan as well. >> Yeah,
he's a weirdo stalker. So here, the problem is people think they
know more than other people do. However, I'm communicating with
my >> I'm learning more and more on the internet that people
Okay, I hate to say it. He's meing. I don't know if he's memeing.
He's He's actually annoyed with the zebra guy. People think that
their stalkers on the internet don't know them. Okay. If somebody
watches you 15 hours a day, all right, sorry, eight hours a day
or something, they know you very well. They always know you very
well. I'm I'm sorry.
I I have to I have to see the the
ramblings be proven wrong on like streamers who stream a ton.
I have to see them proven wrong like once to like start doubting
these people again. All right, they got that Emaru miskf situation
completely correct. They obviously know Darius, right? Hold on
a second. There's a funny situation brewing J at JTO. Kirby is
in love with Darius and she tries to buy Darius's puppy and gives
Darius $3,500. She talks about how if they do that, Darius would
have to be friends with her forever so that they can keep seeing
so that he can keep seeing the puppy. Uh, sounds like an easy
3500 for Darius and a very expensive life lesson for Kerbine.
>> what's going on? She has been part of how I've been
communicating my lawyers and helping me with it. You Mr. Unac
accountable. I'm literally trying to be accountable. Why do you
wait real quick? Why do you think Austin didn't want me from
Oklahoma? Why do you think? Could you tell me? I'm waiting. I'm
waiting.
I'm guessing it would just be expensive to get you extradited
for like low to grade like lowgrade misdemeanor charges. >> You're
not. You have a worn out silly boy. Wait, answer my question.
Or you getting banned? >> Cuz they didn't want to pay the
transfer >> Wait, hold on. When is this? Is this tonight
that he's posting this? Wait, please tell me this is not from
a couple days ago. Please tell me this isn't from a couple days
ago.
Oh, hold on. Wait, what?
Oh, he had he had creatine. Dude, there's no way he got pulled
over for
He he all of this was over creatine.
All of this was over
or is he is he doing this intentionally? Is he like doing a joke
here? That is also probably going to be I don't know. I don't
know the directionality of this. Okay, someone give me my police
report right now. Someone give me my police report now. And he's
like doing this. You're literally not serious.
I hold on I need to see. Give me a second. Top Bronson, what
the [__] going on here? Or Neocick.
Somebody explain very quickly in the
I Somebody added me in the Discord and said, "Look at this."
And it's clear that he's like around with creatine, but I can't
tell if it's from before or if it's from after. What is he doing?
What is he doing? What is he doing? Okay, hold on. They'll explain
it in just a second. Let's continue with the VOD. No >> He
didn't answer. Ban him now. He say I was writing no. So hold
on. I understand Daryus got arrested for speeding. Told him to
search the car and found the straw with creatine. So that's from
before then? Cuz if the straw is from before and it's just the
creatine cuz he was doing a meme. He's trying to show what the
cops saw. Okay. I don't This doesn't do anything. This is
Does he understand? It doesn't mean anything. This I I sorry
I don't comprehend the
the brain.
I I don't comprehend the brain thought process. Okay, I'm going
to show that there could have been a straw with white powder
in my vehicle.
Why would you have white powder on a cre like creatine on a straw?
What are What is the point? What is the meme? Yeah, I understand
this. What is this? Why is it a meme? Why is it funny? This is
so stupid. It's not funny. It's not whatever
going. >> I'm handling it. I'm handling it. People are
talking to proof prosecutors. People are talking to judges. We're
setting up dates. We're talking. The only problem is is my >> is
the warrant not open? I feel like if the warrant's open, isn't
that the entire conversation?
If there's an open warrant, what what is the conversation beyond
that?
Like I'm sorry, you can't if they're if people are trying to
arrest me. I don't know if I can have a conversation to get out
of that. I feel like that's telling pe other people like, "Hey,
arrest this guy." Although I guess
I I felt like, okay, no, they'll they'll deal with it back there.
They don't want to pay to like process this. They're like, oh,
this guy's like fled the state and it's like a low-grade crime.
Cool. He's out of our hands.
my lawyer is too busy to be able to do what we're setting up.
>> His lawyer is actually a loser.
>> So I that's why my lawyer fees are now like 15k cuz
now I have to go ahead and get a new lawyer. >> Again,
my mother's a lawyer. >> You gave consent? Hey, guess what?
I didn't even give consent for them to search me. They just started
doing it. >> that that's something you can actually file
charges >> which I didn't know. I didn't know. I was just
like whatever, dude. Like okay. Like they started searching it
and I thought they asked Kirby cuz they got Kirby to get out
of the car. >> We literally listened to him say they said
can we
He definitely explicitly verbally consented to them searching.
I don't know what what we're talking about >> So they got
me to get out of the car cuz they said we're searching the car.
He gave consent and I was like oh okay. >> Can you check
this out? How much time are we from sitting here? >> It's
It's not bad.
>> you're on cam saying it. Show me. I did not say >> that's
that's what they told me yesterday. So, >> that's what
I'm saying. There's no clip of me saying go ahead and search
my car. I did not say that. Whatever dude isn't know. Okay. Do
you think I said verbatim whatever, dude? Or you think I'm just
summarizing it to a whatever dude as how my vibe was. >> Well,
Prawn didn't have anything on the car. That was the difference.
>> Also, they I Here's the thing. They talked about >> Everyone
say you said it. That's why I I I think you did say it. >> You
probably were like, "Oh, search my car. I have no drugs."
>> Literally told him to search your car. Okay, maybe I
did it. >> But regard >> Dude, what the He's literally
talking on his stream. Oh. Oh, I did. Okay, then I
>> How do you have no idea what the [__] you
were saying the day before? >> Regardless, they were asking
for a K9 unit prior, so they would have searched it no matter
what. No, the Ka No,
the K9 unit is to get probable cause. They suspect you're doing
drugs. They cannot search your car. The canine unit is so that
they can bring the dog around and then if the dog goes, "Hey,
oh, starts barking." That's probable cause in some states. Although,
I think that I think thought they were trying to like um I thought
they're trying to weed this out because the dog the dog can just
be like taught to Yeah. signal immediately. I thought they were
basically trying to make this illegal to try to use this as your
probable cause. Cliffon Claus said you said to search Ro, Lindsay,
I actually unbanned you and I was down with you hanging out here
and then I heard while I was in jail you were being a um I'm
going to give you two messages to apologize before I ban you
and no longer like you again and I will slander your name and
I will do things to ruin your reputation >> and blackball
you. >> Okay. Uh give me one second. I need to use the
bathroom real quick. I'll be right back. two messages to apologize
before I ban you and no longer like you again and I will slander
your name and I will do things to ruin your reputation and blackball
you. So apologize and let bygones be speak bygones. Okay, muted.
You have one more message. Okay, there you go. Banner and Lindsay,
your your tummy literally hangs when you wear squirt shirts.
You literally your stomach literally comes out of the
>> I work out and I have money. She doesn't have money
clearly. >> She lives in the attic of a seven Mexican family
house.
Not only that, she's very hurt that like I won't get my money
back.
I'm okay with that cuz I make a good amount of money. >> Also,
she will get her money back because I actually make money streaming
unlike you. Uh >> even if he doesn't pay me back also good
cuz I also make a lot of money.
>> Lots of money to be had.
>> What I'm saying is >> guess what I got? >> Dude,
another another one bites the dust, guys. That's uh that's rough.
This has to be is is there anything more black pilling? Like
if you were an actual incel, is there anything more blackpilling
than Darius, who's like clearly in so very many ways an obvious
loser, but women are willing to like throw away thousands of
dollars just to be around him. I feel like there must not be
any more blackpilling experience that exists on the internet.
Am I am I wrong? I feel like dude, if I was like alone in the
world, I felt like I couldn't talk to women, this would upset
me like nothing else in the world. This would be like act this
would like actually you'd wake up in the middle of the night
seething about it, right? Cuz he's [laughter] he's like an actual
loser
in so many ways. But women do like
Got got to say it. Okay. Women do like
Uh
also uh this is like borderline
uh Kerbine needs to have some selfrespect. >> Not for my
sake, for her sake. if she wants to be a Darius, if you just
like if you just try to fulfill all of Darius's whims, he will
not like you. He will not be around you, right? The reason he
likes Zena is cuz Zena was constantly like challenging in some
way, right?
If all you do is just say like, "Oh, I I'll pay for everything.
Oh, even if you don't pay me back, that's fine. I got money."
One, where is she getting the money from? And two,
and two, why are you just offering to like have him not pay you
back?
He's like, "Yeah, I'm going to I'm going to pay her back. I'm
making a bunch of money right now. And she's like, "Yeah, even
if you don't pay me back, that's fine, too." It's like a It's
like a comedy skit. >> I won't get my money back. >> Banner.
And Lindsay, >> I got to watch this whole thing. >> My
tummy literally hangs when you wear squirt shirts. >> You
literally Your stomach literally comes out of the shirt.
>> I work out and I have money. She doesn't have money
clearly. >> Wait, is Lindsy
Kerbopine?
Hold on. Do I need Do I need the Lindsy logs here? Give me a
second. Kickhat logs. I might need to go find some logs here.
What? What is happening?
Uh, Lindsy.
Is it It's just Lizzy all as one word, right? Or is there a bunch
of Y's? Give me a second. Give me a second. Oh, this is not No,
this is old. Oh, come on. Is there I don't see Lizzy in the chat,
so they must have gotten banned.
>> She lives in the attic of a seven Mexican family house.
>> Not only that,
she's very hurt that like I won't get my money back. I'm okay
with that cuz I make a good amount of money. >> Also, she
will get her money back because I actually make money streaming
unlike you. Uh >> even if he doesn't pay me back, also
good cuz I also make a lot of money.
>> Lots of money to be had. >> Lots of money. What
I'm saying is >> guess what? I got hotel points for this
weekend. Free vacation. >> Lindsy typing in my >> dude.
You didn't get hotel points for You paid you paid money. What?
She has to have rich parents, right? I feel like there's no other
possible explanation for this. [__] you and your
fat girlfriend is what she said. Okay, I got it. Uh is what Lindsay
said, bro.
She has to have rich parents. This is like insane. Rich parents
and a government job. Okay. All right. It's just It's like crazy.
I listen. Yeah, I paid for everything, but I got I got points.
The 3.5K is from the parents. Okay, >> you guys more people
that have typed into her chat. >> she didn't even type
in her chat to talk about me. You typed in some random like her
I don't know her server. Someone screenshotted it. >> That's
interesting. Okay, you need to stop looking at that. Lizzy has
like one other person in there and it's like this >> No,
someone screenshotted and sent it in your Discord.
>> Oh, when I was >> Who did that? Who did that?
>> Okay, Gift Luck. All right, cool. That's awesome. Gift
luck. You're also banned
>> No, no, no. Seriously, give luck. I don't know why you
do this. I don't know why you consistently.
>> So, just to be clear, it seems like Kerbine either paid
to get him bonded out and like that's what they're talking about
now. I don't even think we've approached this 3.5K we're hearing
about. I don't think that's come up yet. >> Shill for this
nasty like borderline [__] Like, you should just
be banned. You should just be banned. Gift luck, you've lost
your priv privileges. She's
>> Wasn't it you, Glock? You literally did
It just seems like the people want the worst for you. >> Was
it not you? Uh, it might have not been you then. Maybe I was
wrong. I may get I might have been wrong, >> dude. I I
I might have been wrong. Get No, now I feel bad. Yeah, I could
have been wrong.
>> We keep adding charges where any of them are settled.
I will get a lawyer that will handle all of it. So, worst thing
that happens to me will be house arrest or probation. Uh, which
I don't want. >> Maybe it wasn't him. >> I don't
want either one of those things. But, I mean, if that happens,
that's the reality. unfortunate, but it is what it is. Are you
done? >> No. Feel this.
>> That feels pretty heavy.
>> So, I'm
>> No. No. Now I feel bad. I don't think it's Gle. I don't
think it's Gle with the reaction. >> Thought he said, "I
have nothing to hide. Prob doesn't matter because I think they
find a way to search it even if you don't want them to." That's
what I'm saying. I don't think at the end of I think the guy
was very content on me >> so I was researching it even
if it was based off how his [clears throat] actions they don't
have the right to search his car. Um but like he apparently gave
consent. So that's >> you have court on November 13th at
9:00 a.m. Yeah, I know. >> Uh he has also court on another
date. So >> I thank you for looking at my court dates,
dude. I'm I'm pretty sure it's getting pushed though again cuz
>> Yeah, I feel bad. The lawyer has not sent the things
that we need to set up before going there. So,
Um, no, the thing I I was saying that I'm not going to release
uh beforehand. I I'll say it now. >> Your bond conditions
say they can search at any time. Who? >> So, um, real quick,
I'm going to say what um I didn't say in the server. So, the
reason I I was a little quiet about it. It was back and forth.
He was pulled o over by highway patrol. I was talking to a city.
>> What did she hold back on? She literally yapped the
whole time in the discord >> and the
highway patrol wanted to keep him there till Thursday.
And I was going back and forth being like, "No, release him now."
And the city was talking to actually
God bless I have connections in Oklahoma. They were talking to
the judge and the DA and they were able to get him the bond.
God bless. [laughter] I finally can use my connections.
>> Yes. So, pretty much we
>> Does she go into anything about what those connections
are?
got me out.
I don't even know what that means. No, we didn't illegally legally
got you out. But uh we just exped
together and [__] set a bond for you without talking
to you. >> Bro, imagine imagine the hell her parents are
in right now if she's like let them in on what is going on with
this stream and stuff. Imagine the hell her parents must be in
just being able to look up clips of this and just be like, "Your
daughter's like calling. I need to get them out of jail again."
OH >> YEAH. I THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO a courthouse.
You were saying I was going to stay there till Thursday.
They told me that you were and they my my connection in Oklahoma
was fighting with the highway patrol because highway patrol wanted
to keep him there until
>> She put it in Purple Army. Continue bailing out him
for content, please. It's great.
She's never bailed me out for content.
You got bailed out so hard by this girl. Yes, I did. I appreciate
it. >> Uh yeah, this is the best I've ever >> Thank
you. I I've always bragged about connections. You guys always
make fun, but this is actually actually I was able to utilize
connections. And uh >> did they get a viewer call? Yeah,
I told you they got a call. >> This is this is like rough
to watch. >> Yes. I really appreciate I actually reflect
on your life. You
>> dude,
whatever just happened is not even self any sort of reflection
on. Like I don't even know what to say, dude. What just happened
was literally me getting trolled. I will take accountability
for San Diego. I got really drunk. I was emotional
and I was doing too much.
Literally, all the charges on >> every single person that's
ever been this nice to Darius ever, he like ends up just totally
destroying them. Like he he just doesn't consider them at all.
Like there's no way to get Darius to Being nice to Darius is
not something he thinks about, right? That's like his default.
Everybody who's ever been like just only nice to him, it just
doesn't it doesn't work. He's never going to like be kind back.
It's just always going to He's just going to keep withdrawing.
All right, you can't do >> You are so [__]
stupid that I'm sorry. It's really hard for me to like think,
"Oh, yeah. This deserves the extremities
and the disrespect that I've >> There's a lot of spam right
now. Did you get money when they spam?"
>> That's what I'm saying. So, that's what I'm trying to
do. We're trying to get We're trying to get more spam in here.
>> kind of maybe not really. >> Uh, so yeah. So,
TwitchCon
bus Diana is a billboard lawyer. >> No, she's not. She's
She doesn't work for um public defenders office. She uh >> Oh,
yeah. Hold on. >> Hold on a second. >> I totally
forgot. Hold on. I totally forgot. Somebody says if she's got
young cute friends, Darius will try to get with them. I forgot
that he was literally ignoring her to try to hit on the other
girl who Pron who PR brought or something to their hotel room
at TwitchCon, right? He was literally ignoring her and like hitting
on that other girl the whole time. >> Which is very different.
And my >> What does a billboard lawyer mean? >> My
It's just someone. >> Is he Is he trying Is she trying
to be Is he trying to troll me? >> It's It's like he he's
saying that she's like a car salesman, right? Like she she's
not real.
>> So, um
>> I've already said
that. Okay. So, what should I just ban the guy that's spamming
my lawyer's
>> Yeah, probably. The what I'm doing is I'm getting a
new lawyer I think and I'm going to ask >> we're going
to get an actual lawyer. Um when I say we're I'm going to talk
to some legal here and they'll probably have some connections
in Austin. >> You have to answer but Google says the powder
can stay in your system for 3 to 5 days. I haven't done any
>> within that time frame.
>> Stop. Stop. Darius, you're live. You're live. This could
always somehow espec Why doesn't he think of this? He knows.
He knows for a fact that the people who watch him, like some
of them, hate him and they will use anything he says. They will
try to get him in trouble. Why do you say, "Oh, I haven't used
in that time frame." Why do you do that?
>> For 3 to 5 days, I haven't done any
within that time frame. Yeah, you just you just got your you
just got somebody you just used somebody's connections apparently
to get this guy to prison or get this guy to jail for the night
>> really in general. >> I don't know, man. >> I
probably talked to >> She asked him not to say that by
the way
>> Please stop. Please stop saying that. >> That's
why I said I'm I was so okay with a blood test. I was so okay
with them. Like if they wanted to search my car, I was fine with
it, too. Like I'm not really like worried. >> Oh, just
uh real quick. my biggest blood >> while we've got like
Neoick top Bronson watching plant dad when he talks about the
dog does that happen in this vaude or is there something else
I need to >> days if you do I I haven't done coke I'm not
I'm not I'm not even joking >> okay okay all right >> got
arrested complying I know that was my biggest thing I'm like
I complied with you in every way shape or form
>> still before two we can't even check in >> how
much before two >> oh 137
>> talk to eight lawyers
Yeah, I don't >> only happens to Darius. Dead ass. It only
happens to me. I It's because I'm a I'm not even joking. It's
cuz I'm a little and I let I let people me. >> I'm not
kidding. That's a little bit true because I started getting agitated.
>> They were treating him. And he told me, "Calm down.
Stop saying that." And I'm
>> Oh, Darius. Darius doesn't understand. He He had white
woman privilege there. Okay. Yeah. If Zena was freaking out,
that could go badly for you. But a white woman, an affluent white
woman freaking out on your behalf, probably never goes bad. Okay.
>> He yelled at me. He can't even say like, "Thank you,
sir." He can't even say sir to the cops. And he's yelled at me
to [__] calm down. I was like, "No, they're being
unreasonable." And he was like, "No, calm down. I got this."
He can't even say thank you, sir. Like, I understand, sir.
>> [__] I'm so sorry to say you have to call
every cop you ever meet, sir.
>> Yeah, I didn't do that. I messed up there. I definitely
wasn't thinking.
>> I was just I was saying something like along the lines
of like, "Yo, bro."
>> Literally. And that's why they think you're wrong at
it. You probably had the hood on, too. Guaranteed. >> I'm
trying to link. >> It's It's definitely how badly he was
tweaking. He said he was sweating bullets. He was like tweaking
out in the car. Like you could hear it in his voice that he was
freaking the [__] out or I thought he was performing
like the huh I just I just just like I I have only got charges
within the last year and I really don't know what's going on.
I thought he was I thought he was doing a performance for the
stream. But the other explanation is he's just actually freaking
out. But he was definitely he sounded erratic. He sounded like
he was all over the place. >> The cop he like a little
girl. >> He looked like a little girl and he [__]
hated you. >> Like little girl. >> He's closed gay
and he [__] hates you and he's jacking up later for
your arrest. People are saying right now it's a Friday night
on Halloween. >> It might be 6 in deep in her is what it
>> He's 6 in deep in his pillow, my guy.
>> weird.
Should have said, "Well, I understand what he said." Plant dad,
but I think he was also recording the stop with his phone in
his pocket, right? And I think he was acting for stream a little
bit. Like I think he was like making sure he was enunciating.
He was like I thought he was putting on a bit of a bit. Yeah.
>> You look like a thug. You look like a >> You do
look like a [__] >> It just seems weird. Really?
>> That's why like I get scared when like my co-workers
are around. >> I look like a thug. >> You look like
a thug. >> I look like a supermodel. >> You look
like a thug.
>> Whatever. Weren't you zooted off the cola? Weren't you
zooted off the cola? No, dude. I literally drank a 50 g protein
shake before. How did you get a >> They both
listen Porter Beller, you just don't like that he found his own
Nazuite, okay? You just don't like that he found somebody who's
going to support him no matter what and is going to totally destroy
themselves trying to support this guy with absolutely no indication
that it will ever pay off or be fruitful in their lives. Okay.
They're just like, "Oh, he's popular. I should I should be around
this person. Yeah, there's probably more to life. I >> Dead
ass falsely. I really I really wish I genuinely I cannot wait
to see the blood test results. >> So, the funny thing is
if I wasn't with him, I would never believe him, but I was with
him whole entire time. >> Yeah, probably. Almost like it.
>> Charger, is it? Yeah, he's driving it. >> I like
that charger. Spotify rapper fit.
>> I did talk to him. >> At least Darius acts like
he likes her. Yeah, now he does right now. >> Talk to my
mom about him because I she >> Oh, you got this work? >> Oh,
nice. Thanks.
because my mom did work for the public defender and so I was
trying to get her opinion cuz let's calm down about >> false
falsely accused. >> What? We call down the mob giving up
>> They they would never be able to find >> Okay,
let's not challenge them.
>> Dude, why do people do this? Why do Just shut up. Just
shut up. >> I know for this. >> Oh, yeah. Let's not
challenge people. >> Uh, chargers have four doors.
Yeah, that's not a charger. There's a
>> Click the link, Darius. >> Oh my god. >> My
mom's 20 years married. >> Your mom's 20 years married?
>> Over 20 years married. My parents got married 18,19.
They're soulmates. >> Chad, do you guys think I should
give it up? Wrap it up. Like, I should stop streaming. I'm thinking
I think I should stop streaming and I should try to get a >> He
has no This is the height of Darius's earning potential. He will
never make more money from anything than he will from streaming
on kick in this period right now. Uh he should like
I don't think this goes better but like he I don't know that
he'll ever be able to all all that will happen is he would quit
kick he would quit streaming and after like a month his will
would break and he come back to streaming in just a significantly
worse place. So, like for me, I'm like, "Okay, this is probably
going to lead to you getting in trouble more and having more
issues, and it's probably not going anywhere good, but at the
same time, I think you just come back after it after real life
jobs don't go anywhere, and you'd be back to this anyway. So,
you might as well not lose the the viewership while you leave."
>> All right, I'm clicking the link. The link doesn't work.
This is what pops up.
White screen.
>> Wait, hold on.
Darius making money on kick and from tricking women with wealthy
parents. I just want to be clear. Sweatpants freedom. Darius
is not tricking this person. Okay, this is like a spell he has
cast. He is not like hiding who he is. It's all out there. He
lives his own life very explicitly all the time. It's not a trick.
He's basically like I am I am smelly. I am disorganized. I I
have like debts. I get in legal trouble all the time. My life
is constantly advertised on the internet. want to hang out and
they're like, "Yeah, let's do
>> Who's going to hire a criminal? That's what I was thinking,
too. >> I've never heard of sit. >> That's why That's
why I think what I'm going to have to do this year.
>> Oh, hold up real quick. Uh Kevin, I see that you're
asking for the refund of your $1. >> It is an adventure.
>> I uh I'll have to make sure I let PayPal know that you're
trying to refund $5 of donations and I let them know that uh
you have you have been uh given what you wanted. I think he could
just get really smart about stocks.
>> Sorry. Uh actual good investment. >> No, [laughter]
>> dude. He's just he can keep streaming. He's just got
to get really smart about stocks. Okay,
that's that's the issue. We're not smart about stocks.
>> Who is we? >> Us as a team. Chat. >> You
and chat. Yes.
>> Wait, I need to go back. >> That's a classic.
That was a I might have cut off his response a little too much
there. You guys heard it, right? She's like, "He just needs to
get really good at stocks."
actual good investment. >> No, I think we should just get
really good at blackjack.
>> That's his response. >> Who is >> us as
a team? Chat, >> you and chat. Yes.
>> Wait, I need to go back. What was I about to do? Chat
wanted me to look at >> My stock's doing really well right
now. >> All right. Also, BC.Game code. BC.Game games that
they'll give me they'll give me the last five streams that they
owe me. Wow. Day traders are all in on predictive markets right
now. Oh, I love predictive markets and I can't do those. That's
the exact thing I'm actually addicted to is like prop bets that
I think I have like insight on. I I literally can never do Poly
Market or anything like that on a regular basis. I would be I'd
be totally mindful
like I don't I don't need to gamble in like slots that stuff.
I I wouldn't do it because I could probably eventually get myself
addicted to slots or VLTS or something. But like actual just
prop bets that are like fun questions that I think I'm like right
on. Yeah, that would that would bankrupt me pretty quickly.
Or maybe the intro wasn't working because of that. Okay. >> I
don't have wonky eyes. I have fake >> Is this actually
Fancy Sloth?
>> Well, he has a cute girlfriend and cute. >> Did
he get Did he fix himself up?
>> That cannot be Fancy Sloth.
>> That is not Fancy Sloth. My eyes are a fake vampire.
You
>> Darius is now Darius's entire worldview, the entire
basis for him thinking he was doing okay was knowing that Fancy
Sloth was always below him. Okay, that's that's what made Darius
secure in his life. And now suddenly there's like some indications
that that might have flipped. And he's I don't think anything's
shaken. Every time he gets pulled over, every time he's sitting
in jail, he is far less shaken. He's far less shook than he is
right now seeing that picture of Fancy Sloth. Okay, >> that
could be him a little bit. I thought he was Ginger. >> No,
his hairline's like moreed up than >> Are you saying it's
not him? >> He mocks you now. [snorts] >> Did he
get How did he get his teeth
>> That guy got his teeth fixed a long time ago. How do
you not know that lore? I know that lore. >> He lost all
his like teeth in the front. >> Why? Cuz he drugs. >> He
got new teeth. >> Oh, good for him. But his hair's not
the same color anymore. >> He's been crying. Plant dad,
do you like how I've been live for the past couple hours? There's
no way I could have just known that. But I do know it because
I I literally have this guy's brain downloaded as a sub routine.
It takes up like 0.001%
of my brain capacity. I can I can do everything except memes.
Okay. I didn't download his comedy, but the way he actually logically
thinks through and emotionally thinks through situations. Yeah,
100%. I know. I know. Fancy. I know that picture is going to
live in his mind for like the next week.
piece piping. Hannah knows this girl looks like she has
sort of look like him. Hannah's
>> She has two lazy eyes. Okay. >> How did If you
have two lazy eyes, you know what that means? That means they're
even. [laughter] Lazy eye means like one's like way below the
other. If I have two lazy eyes, that means they're >> Someone
find me a picture of Pug right now. Can I get a pug picture?
>> Is that true? I think that's how that works. You have
two. >> Okay. No, that that is. Unless they're like [__]
both >> crazy. But I have fake contacts in as well. So,
believe it or not, I'm You You may have never expected this.
My eyes are fake right now. >> Both are lazy as [__]
Do you know what a lazy eye means? >> Wait, did you give
me the the Red Bull? >> I bought you a Red.
>> Uh-huh. Tell me. Tell me more. >> That one or
the >> Didn't I have the smallest one? Didn't Zeus say
this have the smallest one? Was there something else I need?
>> I got you a protein bar. Thank you. >> You want
it?
So, all my co-workers like uh Oreo the best part at Oreo. >> I
was afraid I wasn't going to hit my macros today. Dude, they
gave me the food they gave me was a pool of syrup and two pancakes
that are like this big. But they gave me this much syrup for
these for two pancakes this size and then a bowl of slop on the
side. I was like, "No, thank you." I literally said, "Please
take this. I wish I could take a picture." I was like, "I'm okay
on breakfast. Can I get the phone, please?" I was like, "Dude,
am I supposed I I was like, "Dude, am I supposed to like swallow
the syrup?" I didn't know. It was like I was I think >> Jojo
in Japanese was from my ex-boyfriend's mom. Fun fact.
>> Wait, what? >> This is from my ex-boyfriend's
mom. It's the kindest gift I've ever got. It's my name in Japanese.
>> I'll get you a new one.
>> Pure gold.
>> What do you have to do to go all your
>> Uh, I don't know. >> Okay. We need to get to whatever
this dog part is. Okay.
How far are we away? >> They'll pay you. >> There's
no way they just sit here. Yeah, >> pay you $3,000 for
Chichi. >> Oh, I literally I literally >> wish cast
that. Okay, I made that happen. Yes, they will. But um my parents
will take Chi-Chi for $3,000. They'll pay you $3,000.
>> They'll pay you $3,000 for just fun >> When did
they say that? >> They've told me that. >> They'll
pay you $3,000 for Chi.
>> I will I can tell them and they will pay you that. >> Counter
35. Huh? >> Counter 35. >> Yeah, they they'll do
it >> and they'll take them or you'll take >> They
will take Chi and raise Chi and Chi will be in the most beautiful
amazing environment in the world. >> What about you? >> Uh
well, it's my family. I could take her back. Like, it's my family.
I could [__] do. >> Oh, this is actually a
longterm game anyway. Yeah.
>> Bro, these dynamics are not great. >> You have
to give them the registration. You have to give them everything.
They will take Gigi for a while. >> Are you okay with that?
They'll train her. They'll do everything.
And they'll give you money. They'll give you 3500. >> I'll
get her back in. I'll get her back
>> Wait, what do you think, chat?
>> But Chi will be 100% original. It's huge property.
Great great great um layout. Uh my older dog, Blue, is the most
perfect angel in the world, and they will get along very, very
well. They'll be boyfriend, girlfriend.
If you want to do it, >> it's better for the dog. It is
better for the dog. >> This is like This is I have I'm
having a hard time coming up with words for this dynamic. This
is not good. >> It is better for the dog. I >> right
now it's got to a point this legal stuff has got to a point where
I can't train her. >> So my mom will train her. My mom's
up there and uh >> this is not great. >> 3500 that
they give you.
>> It's not even that you give them to go. It's gonna I
guarantee you it's gonna be like third if this were to happen
it' be like 3500
and and then Kerbine would take the dog and give it back to Darius
and then there'd be a big fight about it cuz I guarantee there's
no way they're like oh we'll spend $3500 just to be able to train
that dog for him for like four weeks and then you could take
it. >> Go train her and do all this. >> I won Chi.
>> you're selling Chi-Chi to me. So you if you want to
ever see Chi-Chi again, you have to continually be friends with
him. Oh, I know. It's heartbreaking. >> Well, I'm gonna
live with you soon. >> Uh, that's crazy. Crazy statement.
It will help with your leave. >> So, high by back at a
dip. That's smart, >> dude. She just wants to give him
money for lawyer fees. That's like actually what all she wants.
Just anything anything to be able to keep hanging out. It's This
is crazy, man. This is >> We'll help you with your legal.
>> Do you think they'll resell to me for
I think they'll give it to me and then you'll have to talk to
me about it. >> Oh, Chi-Chi's also not even fixed.
>> Uh, I just don't believe her parents would do that.
Why would they pay money for that for a random dog? Now, I wouldn't
pay $3,500 for that dog, but I would Wherever Darius is getting
those dogs from, those are the cutest dogs in the world. I like
bar none. They're like the cutest dogs in in the entirety of
Earth. Okay, they're like the they're so cute. There's something
to willing to be uh like being willing to pay for that dog for
whatever dog breed that is. Whatever mix he's getting those dogs
from.
Those are like Yeah, those are absolutely adorable dogs. >> Ew.
Uh we're going to get >> They're like little teddy bears.
>> It's a lot. I know it's a lot, but these are something
that could help you out a >> here. This is uh I'm pretty
sure this is Chi-Chi and this would be GMO, right? This looks
like a younger like more of a puppy. This looks older, but this
is like the cutest thing in the world. Holy [__]
So, I understand wanting to be able to pay money. I would never
pay that much cuz that seems insane. Like an insane amount to
me, but I would want to know where he gets these dogs from so
I could get one. Uh, okay. Contrarian
contrarian contrarian take over here. >> You never lose
Chi-Chi. What would you do if you're Whoa. Whoa. Abortion
>> 4,500 and it's a deal. >> Wait, where where did
this happen? J stock arc. Wait, what? There's no way that's the
reason why she's gonna pay for this stuff.
Please say just say JK right now. Say JK right now. Say JK right
right the now.
>> I'll have to talk to my parents, but um I think that
seems like an unfair deal considering how much >> How much
was you?
You don't even know >> Darius.
how much I'm recently also helping you with parents connection.
I think this is unfair. >> Chi-Chi is a famous dog. >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> Did I miss?
>> I'm pregnant. So, you never lose >> What would
you do if you're >> Whoa, whoa. Abortion
>> 4500 and it's a deal. >> Oh, he's still driving
the price up. I
But um I think that seems like an unfair deal considering how
much >> how much was
you don't even know >> Darius
how much I'm recently also helping you with parents connection.
I think this is unfair. >> Gi is a famous dog. >> I
think 3,500 and I can potentially get her back in DC. Seems very
fair >> to keep her
>> that they get the they get everything to >> They
just want to dude they're so rich. They just want to buy stuff,
dude. They just they they literally just That's why if you had
a fetus, they would just be like, "Yeah, 5,000 for the fetus."
And they give you back the fetus. It's like buying Charlie Sheen's
dog. That is true. 37.50.
Look at Let's get Let's get an auction stream with them. And
then >> So, they offer 3,000. I'm bringing it up to 3,500.
>> Okay, we can keep it up there. Not the Not the money
makes you want to get rid of her, but right now
we have Dono. We have so many dogs at the house and it's >> Don't
you understand how silly you're
Depends how >> if if Darius cared about that dog, somebody's
willing to take that dog off his hands for for a cost, he should
listen. Let that dog go. Let that dog go live a happy life. Let
that dog go get trained. Okay.
Come on, man. >> If you want to cut me off and never talk
to me again, cuz I can get the dog back
>> I don't know if that's even true. >> I can >> I
think if your parents bought the dog, I think they would dead
ass. >> No, a dead ass. They're buying the dog because
I am in love with the dog and they were like, "Oh, our daughter's
so depressed." Were you ever into horses growing up? >> Oh,
what? No, dude. Dude, dude, I
I I
can't I
[laughter] Oh my god, dude.
This is not I hope her parents see that this is not the solution.
This is not the solution. This is not the solution. >> No.
Um I had horses. No, I didn't have >> Riy. I literally
can't control the automod. The auto mod is off as much as it
can be. Kick does the rest. The automod is set to as low as it
can possibly go and kick automods the rest. >> Ran out
of horses growing up and like I like them.
So that was the thing. How are you processing that? >> I'll
keep it in mind. >> I don't want a horse. I don't want
>> No, I was curious like your parents are like, "Oh, my
my daughter loves horses." So the whole thing with the dog is
I am I've become completely attached to the dog that they could
tell that I was very very depressed after the dog left and they
said we will buy the dog off day.
>> Is that done? >> I I can knock it out so we can
go on.
>> How much you want to bet? How much do you want to bet
that the real reason that this stuff was happening? Okay. The
real reason they said this was they're like oh she was like I'm
going to go hang out with Derry so I can see the dog again. And
they're like we'll buy the dog. Just don't go there. Just don't
go hang out with this guy. We'll buy the dog. Yeah. 3500 bucks
if that if that's what gets us out. Yeah. 35. Yeah. Easy. Easy
money.
>> Can you actually treat you like a goat? That I was thinking
of, dude. >> But like here's the thing. We have a theme
of every woman in our life leaving. Maybe she has to go for a
little bit. We have legal stuff going on, guys. It's getting
to a point. >> That's that's so silly cuz she's going to
be taking care of so well. My parents live in a paradise
and my mom loves >> That's why. That's why. That's why.
>> and you'll get a pre 30,000 or over 3,000. We can negotiate.
>> Yeah. Let's keep Let's keep this in mind. Let's keep
this conversation for tomorrow after we have good night's
>> Uh this was brought up to me uh in San Diego and I didn't
want to bring it up to you yet cuz I didn't think you would receive
it. Well, >> yeah. I don't really want to get rid of my
dog, but I also understand my situation is pretty gnarly right
now and I'm in a very like >> bad position. And also my
house situation right now is not the best environment. So I do
>> and stand the rich girl bragging. The connections thing
is what's more annoying to me. Like it's just it's
just that her parents know people. There's like nothing. She
didn't get her own connections. She's just like talking to her
parents and being like, "Help help my boyfriend get out of jail."
>> I am enticed by the idea,
>> but I'm not getting much of a profit on >> Drink
how much in paper? >> That's my own business. Well, you
should tell me that and then >> I was doing really well.
>> How much was your paper? >> Good chunk change.
>> How much? Mute it. Tell me.
>> Mute it. Tell me right now. You know, I can convince
people. >> Mute it. >> No. Stop. I'm not going to
do mute. I'm not going to say it. >> Why? I'm helping you
out.
>> New trip for Hannah. No. >> The 3K would be literally
just more >> If you did a new trip for Hannah, I would
never [__] talk to him again. I'm not going to lie
to you. If if you ever like [__] do all this, if
Hannah like showed up tomorrow and was like, "Oh, I want to go
all this." I I'm never talking to you again,
dude.
He would
Oh, why is she Why would you say this? Why would you put this
on
We all know he would be out the door in a second if Hannah was
like, "Oh, I made a mistake." Like in a millisecond.
And I I feel like her putting this she just put this into the
universe. I feel like she just gave him like an idea. I feel
like she gave Hannah an idea.
Like I'm I'm not Listen, I didn't watch very much of the last
Hannah arc. Okay. But I have no I fully It would be fully within
character for me to think Hannah sees this and is like, hm,
maybe we cook. Maybe we cook.
I got to back it up again. Just more
>> What's that? Sure.
>> I would never talk to him again. I'm not going to lie
to you.
If if you ever like do all this, if Hannah like showed up tomorrow
and was like, "Oh, I want to go all this." I I'm never talking
to you >> Somebody needs to tell This is uh I'm feeling
less and less bad for Kerbopene as she says this. Okay, brief
character synopsis. Like manic pixie dream girl, but uh like
younger mixed girl with piercings and stuff. Just like Manic
total Manic Pixie dream girl energy. But um I feel less and less
bad for Kerbene cuz I also think this is like what rich people
get in their minds. They're not rich, but like rich girls when
they get everything from for money when they like they just purely
transactional. She's just like she thinks that hey, I've I've
paid for stuff for you. Now you have to like be mine.
That's not how works, man. That's not how works at all.
I This is goofy. This is some goofy to be to put this out there
on stream.
>> He's smiling by the way. He thinks it's >> No,
that's okay. Like I know I'm not saying that's okay. Like Oh,
>> I'm not going to be your friend. I'm >> saying
No, I'm saying like I understand.
>> I just saw Excel. Ronnie, are you here? I just saw you
type in his chat. Hannah getting Chi-Chi. Yeah, I think I could
see it. Okay. I could definitely see it. >> Okay. Like
Yeah. Be okay with that. >> Yeah, you should be cuz like
uh what again? I've done a lot for Darius and I I appreciate
Darius and I I think he's in a lot of unfortunate scenarios.
What I did this past weekend, I put my I put my my reputation
on the line >> for him this weekend and um really bad.
>> You don't have to tell me that. I know what you did.
>> Put it in the trash. Put it in the >> Am I going
>> Bro,
you have She put her reputation on the line. I hope I hope that's
not true.
What part of the repeated violations of your your bond, the repeated
violations of the law, the inability to just like go a week without
getting arrested, getting like like detained by the police? Which
part of these situations made you go, "Oh, I'll put my reputation
on the line for this guy." That's all he needs. Somebody to give
him one last chance. That's all he needs, guys. Somebody to to
come along and go, "Oh, Darius, you know what? I believe in you."
That's all he needs. Okay. >> She buys my dog and then
gets plowed by a 6'4 linebacker while she watches. >> What?
Huh? Wait. What? What? What? What? I
Okay.
>> She paid for his bond, Kger. She paid for his bond.
She's clearly been paying for the whole time for both of them,
right? She just said she got points for paying for the hotel.
She's now trying to set up her parents buying Darius's dog from
him for thousands of dollars.
Okay, this is not good. [snorts] >> All right, can you
pull up the maps? >> Darius says cut fantasies. I have
no doubts. Okay, hold on. It might be that she didn't pay for
the bond. She said she's been helping him in terms of like with
money and stuff, but it's possible she just means getting her
parents to call and like put their reputations on the line or
something to let him go.
>> I'm trapped. I'm trapping you.
No, I don't know if this trapping cuz there I like Chi-Chi a
lot, but I also understand right now that I I got her during
a I think what when did I did I get her right after the restraining
>> I don't know. >> I got her and I was expecting
to stay in my house.
Hold on. Let's see here.
D is so insecure about his height. He's It's pathetic.
hold on. She's jealous. She's jealous. Please, if you love your
dog, give her to the family. Yeah, I mean this is true. Sorry,
you guys probably can't see any of this stuff.
Oh boy.
>> Oh god. And then I got incredibly depressed and I was
like, I need to just go out. Um >> I I remember we were
talking for a bit and you kept telling me that you wanted to
get another dog and I kept telling you no cuz that makes no sense
cuz you can't take care of it.
>> Okay. Who is this guy? Oh, what is this guy in here?
He's This guy's in here taking this seriously. Hold on. Let me
pull this up.
Okay, fellers. enjoy your totally healthy obsessions or whatever.
Uh, we will love and attraction aren't rational, dude. Hopefully
you know this. Okay,
[laughter] this is like, who is this? This is somebody. This
is somebody in one of these communities. This is I don't know
who it is. It's somebody we talk about on this stream. That is
like an alt for somebody who who is talked about on this stream.
I don't know if it's Darius. I'm not going to quite say it's
Darius. I don't know that it's even somebody on this stream we're
watching right now, but that is someone who's like, "You guys
are like obsessed. This is really unhealthy." I hope you just
Sometimes people are just normal, man. We know these people aren't
normal. That's That's like
That's so far in our rearview mirror, we don't even think about
it anymore. >> And then you got one. >> Yeah, because
I felt like I couldn't do it cuz I was going to spend a lot of
time at home, but then the legal stuff just got worse and worse.
So, >> it wasn't the legal stuff. That was before the legal
stuff. Well, my legal that was I'm pretty sure I got the restraining
order on me before I got
>> chat. Is that true or wrong?
>> Is the Oh, there's apparently some rant about sushia
coming up. Okay. >> You were doing a road trip right after
getting the dog. I did do a road trip after getting the dog.
No, that's because we had to come from Washington DC back to
uh that's when we got the car. That's why >> you let a
woman drive. I don't know. Is there any way they bond you out
for a DUI and then let you drive? Like he almost certainly can't
drive, right?
There's no way they like bond you out in Oklahoma and then they
let you drive in Oklahoma with a DUI.
Like the DUI charges there. They must keep you off the road until
it's like for a while,
>> Uh I'm uh 26. >> They take your license. Well,
lucky for Darius, he didn't have a physical license on him to
begin with. Boom. >> He doesn't shoot. was bigger. >> Just
slow down and let them pass me off. Just slow down. But
>> Uh, it's it is 75. I mean, whatever you >> I rather
I rather [__] break fast than >> Try to pass
me. >> No, no, you're fine. You're turning right. You're
turning right literally.
>> Turning left. Left, left, left, left,
>> Oh, wait. Darius is driving then. She's saying left,
left, left. Darius must be >> right? I give you. Okay.
>> You're too old. Uh,
Bum like Darius. I'm too old. I'm 26. I feel like that's not
too bad. It's It's bad. It's getting bad. >> Okay, Joey
Floss. >> Freaking out. >> But everyone tells me
like, >> "Oh god, please don't I Dude, I Please don't tell
that that chat your insecurities. That's going to get If she
wants to do IRL streaming, she needs to not be telling other
people her insecurities. Okay, that's that's a rough one, dude.
Hold on. Hold on. Can I Let me pull up my
Do you guys see this? The Evo psych person is in Darius's chat.
This is from Darius's chat. A people of all ages date all kinds
of people, good bit, good and bad. Just be or but B just let
people live their lives in peace. Lauo,
who is this? This is somebody who's in one of these communities.
It's somebody who's like, "This is really weird to just watch
other people's stuff." >> Like, it's not that bad. >> Everyone
tells you what's not that bad. She needs a man.
>> I am a man. >> I I've said many times
I I'm kind of good with be the being the bread winner. I think
that's fine.
>> What are we talking about? >> No, I think I I
think just like uh >> fell in I mean uh he has zero savings.
Do you have zero savings? Do you think >> I have zero savings?
>> How all my savings is now going towards his employer
fees. Now I know I did have
Thought I was until I came home. I thought I was just going to
My lawyer pretty much was telling me that
>> uh my lawyer said everything's going to go away after
the next court date. But when I came back, my ex did something.
>> If I'm honest and like nice right now, my parents are
going to give me give you up to $4,000 for that dog. I think
you should give the dog to them because they'll be my bad,
What is happening?
Did you Did you guys hear that? I also might have blown your
ears out with the soundboard because she was definitely very
quiet. She just said, "My I'll be nice to you. My parents can
give you up to $4,000 for the dog." All right. Up to 4K for the
dog
and then they'll just give it back to me.
Bro,
she's literally explaining how you could extract maximal value
out of her parents. Darius, here's how you can get the most money
out of my parents right
>> I'll see.
>> You have a big smile on your face. I'm
>> I'm serious. You should give them the
>> You should give them Chi. >> I know it sucks,
but like to get like $4,000 to give my parents Chi-Chi and they'll
trade her. She'll they'll trade her like the military, right?
She'll be amazing. I have another dog up there that's amazing.
And uh I mean I love my parents so going to get that dog back.
>> What if they told me the dog back? I don't think your
parents >> they they would. My mom literally calls their
current dog >> right now. Call right now.
>> They're going to call her They're going to call her
mom right now to prove that her mom will pay for this dog. Will
your mom really pay $4,000 for this dog? >> You want it
to be straight?
>> Hi. How you doing?
H interesting.
>> I got to get my phone.
>> I got to get my phone. >> I'm waiting.
>> So, uh I I was talking to him about the dog deal.
>> Yeah. Um
is there any like uh point of time that I could get the dog back
or I could pay you guys to get the dog back or anything like
that?
>> What do you mean? So, let's say I sell the dog or we
sell the dog to you for 3,000, 4,000, whatever price. >> Whatever
dad said. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Whatever my dad said. Um,
is there a way to get the dog back after a few months or
>> No. Hey, can we like get can we get like 4K and then
we just get the dog back eventually? That's not how this works,
bro. It's already totally unimaginable that they give Darius
$4,000 for this dog and that's not enough. It's like, can we
just get the dog back after, too? Can we just have 4,00 Can I
just have
and you train the dog and you take care of the dog and then you
give me $4,000 and then once the dog behaves better, I can just
have the dog back. >> You buy something, you can buy it
back. >> Well, I mean, I'm family with you. I would hope
I can buy the dog back. >> No. No. No. That was not the
deal of your damn fer on this. >> Okay, then we have to
talk about this. How How do I make that happen? >> You're
talking to the wrong person. I didn't come up with any of this.
>> Can I get the dog back if the dog stays with you for
a few months? >> I'm asking you. I'm asking I'm asking
the owner of the household.
>> I It would be too crushing for Blue. He's already >> I
love Blue to to death.
>> You have a little sister, too?
>> No, he already lost his brother. So, it'll be back and
forth. It'll be back. So, it'll be two. It seems like Okay, hold
on. I have to reconnect my headphones really quickly. It seems
like what's happening here is they have another dog who they
want a companion for, like another dog that lives with them,
right? And they're looking for one anyway, probably. And this
is the dog. They they want this dog. And it's like, oh yeah,
we're buying this dog to have a companion for our other dog.
And obviously, we're not going to give the dog away if if we
buy it for that, right? Give me a sec. I just got to reconnect
these headphones. There we go.
Oh, R.
It's back. Okay, it's back. Yeah. So, I think I think that's
what it sounds like is basically they don't want their dog to
live without another animal.
>> The daughter blew her cover. >> I will take the
dog back and forth. >> No, I'm not. I'm not talking about
this. >> I've driven across the US so many times now. Come
on. You got to trust me.
>> Who do I have to talk to? Who do I have to talk to to
make this happen?
Yeah.
He's going to get killed. All right. I got just got here.
>> I think you think
>> No, I don't at all. >> Dude, that is an insane
request.
Can you pay us $4,000
and then just like give the dog back?
What What kind of life has has she lived where her parents just
like give her anything everything totally do on her? Was she
expecting She was like expecting that to work. She She like She
fully is like shocked that that didn't work.
That's crazy. I was trying
>> What would happen
would have to date
>> big thing for you.
>> Well, your phone's here. But I had to plug in my phone
to die.
>> Uh God draws.
My mom is a blueberry. The dog, they love Chi-Chi and they love
aspect of me like having to visit them all the time because of
Chi-Chi. Cuz I'm so in love with Chi. So,
they're really happy about it. My parents would take amazing
care of the dog. It just depends on where it is. Like, you really
have to commit to at least our friendship.
>> Why? Why?
Why is she doing this? Why?
You have to commit to at least our friendship. Commit right now.
>> See the dog on time. We got to be best
>> We're very close friends, >> dude. Hannah I swear
to God Hannah is watching this like Heath Ledger's Joker right
now. She She's just getting ready to cause some chaos. I can
I can hear it. I can feel it. It's like 100% happening. Hannah
is just watching this. She's like, I'm ready to burn this whole
thing down. She's She's, by the way, she's not going to do it
until that dog gets sold. She's going to wait for that dog to
get sold. She's going to wait to like maximize all of the impact
and then she's just going to make a phone call. All right, >> we
would have to say that. That's what I'm saying. >> I mean,
it's a
>> it's a great deal for you. >> Even if like I just
>> By the way, I fully believe Darius thinks he could stay
friends with this woman because when he describes when she's
like, "We have to stay friends forever." He's like, "Yeah, we'll
be we'll [__] all the time whenever you want." That's
in his head what he's thinking right now. 100%.
That's not what she's thinking. That's what he's thinking, though.
>> It's a really really
>> What's up?
I don't know. It's breaking up. So, I [__] It's tragic
that the audio is going out for this.
>> Hold on.
>> I don't know if I can face her. >> You're gonna
You're >> Oh, sorry. What's she thinking in terms of
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What's she thinking in terms of we need to
be friends? I think she is doing the simp thing. It's just weird
on a girl instead of a guy. I think she's doing the simp thing
where she's like, "We just need to be friends. We need to be
close cuz eventually you're going to realize that you love me
and we're going to be together." I'm That seems to be what's
going on.
Imagine Oh, Gift Luck. Gift luck's hitting her hard in the chat.
Imagine a dude saying this to a girl. Every person would call
him a manipulator.
Yeah. pathetic too.
>> Okay, we need to start writing the arc. Can somebody
get these clips to like Wasn't Kerbene doing the Wick dating
stream with Nonfon? Can we get these clips to Nonfon? Can we
get Nonfon to like start? He needs to make his move here. Okay,
Nonfon is the only person who can save Kerbine from Darius. All
right, I can see it. I can see it already. I see it very clearly.
This is the only way that she ever escapes. All right, we need
Non to step up. step up and and lay out the riz that Wick taught
him. Okay, this is he's like Luke Skywalker coming back in Return
of the Jedi. All right, Wick is Yoda, Non Nonfon is Luke, and
Darth Vader is Darius. All right,
>> it's fantastic. >> This is going to get really
awkward when Nonfon learns that he's his dad, but it's fine >> a
little bit. >> That happened in Empire, but it's fine.
>> Yeah, I'm just worried. Here's the thing. I just I I
don't I think that it's a good idea for me just because the position
of it is really bad. But I
>> Has the Darius content become so played out that the
meta is just cold reading his future now? Wait, the meta's always
been cold reading his future? Because that's not even a challenge.
I mean, maybe it's a challenge for some people. It's not a challenge
for me. It's just always it's always been the thing I do when
I watch his content cuz I've just I watched a lot of his content.
Yeah, it's it's
Yeah, we're just pondering the orb. We're not It's not cold reading.
It's just pondering the orb. I see it clearly.
The the nonfont thing is is me like trying to weave stuff though.
Like I'm trying to make that happen.
>> GG is very but also she's very bad
because I am probably >> It's so silly. Like um >> it's
really bad. >> Well, you heard the conversation. She would
probably never if she' probably not be able to give it back.
>> Yeah.
[clears throat] That's why it's it's a I guess it's more difficult
for
friends. How long? >> Ignore the friend part. All this
other stuff is more just like I need to get I need to can make
an adult decision and I need to be an adult.
>> Ignore the friend part.
>> Get off me. >> I think he said 3500 is what he
take. >> A better life. I don't want it to >> Then
stay friends with me and you'll see the dog.
>> Okay. Don't talk like that cuz it sucks. But uh >> Oh
god, I'm just Hold on. I'm just realizing um wait, where's the
Nick's message? I'm realizing that he asked her what she'd do
if she got pregnant and she was like, "Oh, abortion immediately."
And now in my head I'm like, "Oh, I don't I don't think I think
that's selling a false sense of security to someone." That's
>> that I would. >> Oh, dude. Hey,
>> why is the audio cutting out? >> What? I I'm trying
to think of what's best for the dog.
>> Are you Cuz it would be with my parents. >> Yeah,
I think that would be what's best for the dog. >> We have
a ginormous [__] property that the dog
like.
>> Come on. Come on. Come on. >> He's in residential
[__] >> Like, thanks for [__]
>> Why did you say that?
>> Dying. I'm dying. I'm dying every time the audio goes
out cuz it's all >> You said, "Oh, he's going to have
live right now." >> You would just say no. You say, "Bill,
that's crazy."
>> I said something crazy. >> Is he saying that about
her dad? >> About her brother. I told you. >> I don't
know. I >> You're be [__] >> Actually,
go back. >> Yeah. Something about an family member that
dog, which that's what Yeah. It wasn't just something about an
family member was that the family member would the dog stream
dies. Okay, we're coming
>> doesn't spend any money
rattling him again.
so like
>> uh we got really lucky in that one.
>> I made best friends with the dude at the the counter
and it was so awesome. He didn't charge me for the second night.
We got really lucky. Um
>> I mean [laughter]
>> dude Neo is saying Moneybags curb is going to drag is
going to get Darius out of jail and she's like she's oh she's
good for Dar for to Darius. I think you mean she's too good to
Darius but Darius was like she doesn't spend money on me. She's
like yeah I've spent a lot of money on you >> when I had
a direct money I dog >> because it's not even about like
I'm trying to think about it. It's not even that like I want
to get rid of the dog. I know like I really
that's look at what just happened
that's never what I thought or intended. It was more like >> she
will like you are chaotic chaotic everywhere and >> like
if that would ever happen to people like them. >> My mom
my mom told me that she could take over for a while.
>> But I convinced my parents to get the dog back. Like
come on.
>> I'm close with my parents. Oh, I uh by the way, we'll
have another stream after this. There's another Darius stream.
But I do need to chill cuz I don't know how much time we got.
We got an hour left on the stream. Guys, if you like the content,
go ahead, follow on every platform. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstylk.
Uh, and if you really like the content, you can throw a couple
bucks my way, make the stream go for longer. I think we're four
subs away from another two hours on the stream. All right,
you can sub on kick. You can give subs on kick. It's a 955. It's
a 955 split. Goes directly into my bank account. All right. Uh,
if you can individually sub, I really appreciate individual subs.
All right? I know they fall off for people sometimes. So, if
you individually sub, that's like recurring monthly income that
I can plan around. Really appreciate anybody who individually
subs. But if you've just got extra cash and you want to help
people out, you can give subs as well. All right. Exclamation
point donate in the chat. It will give you the links. If you
want to buy a TTS message, have your message read on stream.
Exclamation point donate. All right. There is the There is the
Streamlabs link. There is the Kickbot link. What do you mean
another stream after this? You mean tomorrow? No, there's a stream.
Literally, this is from yesterday, 21 hours ago. Darius stream
today. I'm probably going to go cover that for a quick second.
All right,
so you guys listen,
there's all the ways you can donate. I don't know if the donate
link went through. There's Streamlabs. There's Kickbot as well.
All right, and last but not least, there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
Get in. We've I think we've done like three calls this week.
I don't know. If we end at 4 hours tonight, we might do another
call. We'll see.
Um Oh, I I can't see the membership tiers. There's multiple tiers.
All right. Supporter tier is going to get into most of the calls.
Sometimes I'll do an oiler specific call, but I'm trying to get
just more people participating. So, we're going to do we're going
to do supporter tier for a little while and then we'll see if
we ever go back to the order calls. Probably if things get too
hectic in the supporter calls, but I haven't been doing them
for a long time. So, I'm just trying to get people even people
who have all this. I'm just trying to get them to show up, you
know. All right. Thank you very much anonymous for the five gifted.
Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. That is what? That's
two hours and
one sub carries over. So, we'll go. We'll throw three hours up
there. Let's go. Let's continue.
>> Thank you very much. Anonymous. >> They pay you
like $3,000. They need the >> No, they want to keep her,
bro. They're >> They're going to give it back.
They probably won't. They're going to fall on my mom. I'm not
going that is going to fall on my mom. Like she will never leave
my mom's side. I never in fact I I've dealt with she will never
leave my mom's side. She >> come on
>> there. That's That will be cheating with my mom. >> I
know they're going to have a good time. I'm not worried about
that. I'm just more like >> I can get the dog back. >> I
know some of them are quite late. I know, bro. Come on, man.
>> How is this audio like this? Oh, they definitely muted
now.
>> They definitely muted. I don't use my money for game
this work. Like I use my money for game. I use $500. I don't
know. That's it. Like last year I spent $500 a month for money.
That's it. >> But the uh
the offer say
>> my Here's what I'm thinking in my mind. I need to figure
out if we'll see. We need There's one more. There's like a sushia
piece of content in here. Like he rants about sushi or something.
All right. After we watch that, we're going to move over and
watch the Hannah stream from a couple days ago. I think it's
like a week ago just to see when when Kervine says if you go
back to Hannah like that it's so over dude. Uh we're going to
go watch him rant about Hannah and just see how likely that'll
be >> to quit doing IRL because if I quit >> it doesn't
even matter.
They're going to fully train a [__]
>> You can't train your dog. How my mom's going to train
your dog? You can't tell him you right now. I can get your dog
back. It's my parents. I should know. You should sell the dog
to them. I'm I'm serious. I'm serious.
At least $3,000. You should give the dog to them and I can get
the dog back. >> I don't think you can get the dog back.
>> I promise on my promise on my life you get the dog back.
I know I can.
>> No, the only reason they want to adopt the dog is cuz
they saw how depressed I was after. They want me to keep coming
>> She didn't get shut down by her mom. Evil Johnny Bravo.
What got shut down was her mom was offering the money. They'll
still offer the money. They'll pay for the dog. They'll they'll
they'll like 10x how much that dog cost Darius easily, right?
What they won't do is do that and then say, "Oh yeah, now now
that we love the dog, here you can have it back." They're saying
if we buy the dog, we're keeping the dog. We're buying that dog
cuz we're going to like love that dog.
>> I know.
>> I like more than I like more than you do. I can tell.
I like
>> I think she is still soft pedaling it.
>> He went to other channels too. He never
>> Fancy sloth can go live just to stream South Park Darius's
girl and get a way more viewers.
>> Oh no, the fancy sloth.
>> oh. Uh
>> Not good. I I would I I just think that
I mean I don't even want the dog to be with my parents necessarily
cuz like I rather take care of the dog. But >> they are
going to do that. >> Um they're going to give me money
again. They they won't be fully trained. That's
>> she's 26. I think she said I'm going to be 27 soon.
>> You have to
dog. >> It's going to be my dog. You're just going to have
to like I said talk to me longer. I don't like that.
>> Sorry, bro.
>> The chat is very funny.
>> You guys are funny about my
>> This is Plantad. Actually, if she she'll give you 3500
for the dog. Imagine how much she'd give you if you agree to
date
>> 16. I feel like your dog. >> You're so funny cuz
like I am like I
and she's screaming at me non-stop. >> Okay. What does
that mean to me? >> And what it means to you is like my
mom needs my attention at all times. She's that dog is mine because
she wants to talk to me non-stop. >> You are going to manipulate
your mom
>> So you're going to So you want So you want me to say
okay I can give you
Uh, [laughter]
I get $4,000 for the dog that I love and I would love to be a
better father. >> She's going to give what's going to happen
and
>> what's going to happen is she's going to give you $4,000
to a dog for the license, right? She's going to take care of
it and bring it for a month or two, right? While you're figuring
your [__] legal [__] out and then what's
going to happen, >> it's not a guarantee
is going to happen is not a guarantee. >> I know it's a
guarantee.
>> You literally are not close with your parents. like
the whole
>> Oh man, I could just see. Hold on. Oh, plant dad's responding
to BB Poison. Hold on, BB Poison. It's very telling that her
mom ended the call with her immediately with her insane request.
It's not her first rodeo. Surely, I feel like Herbine has been
like, "Listen, I met a guy and all he needs is like $5,000 to
start his small business, okay?" Like, but it's it's Herbal Life.
It's like it's one of those like million different pyramid schemes
like an MLM. I feel like I feel like that's a call her mom has
experienced 100%. Is Kerbafine trying to get her boyfriend enough
money to start like the MLM entry package. All >> I'm going
to call my mom every single >> I know you like >> I
know.
So I call her every single day. So she'll take the dog for two
months and give it back right after you're done with your legal
cases.
>> No, she won't. Are you okay with that? >> She
said explicitly the opposite. She said the opposite explicitly.
Never mind. Now she is arguing explicitly that she can get the
dog back. And her mom said, "No, that's absolutely not how this
works." >> No, not like >> Not only did she say that's
not how it works, she was like, "That would defeat the entire
purpose of buying the dog. We got the dog to try to help out
our other dog that's feeling sad because the the previous like
second dog they had is
>> Won't happen. >> No, it won't. >> You're
hoping You're hoping that >> You're so cute. I'll never
talk to her again. And the threat of me nectar talk me the dog.
>> That's crazy.
hold on. That's a very That's a very quick change up. No, no,
no, no, no, no. You guys, you guys missed the change up. No,
no, no. You missed the change up.
Now I feel like that was our first instance of her seeing what
Chad is saying and seeing what Darius is doing. And now she's
leaning into it to say it was a bit the whole time. It is not
a bit. That's the first step and and she's going to keep escalating
and say it's a bit No, I think she's going to start I don't think
I don't think she's that far gone that she could say this. Okay.
I don't think she's that I think she's starting to she realizes
that she was saying some crazy and so now she's leaning back
into like oh it's just a bit guys just a bit.
>> So you So you want me to bank on you manipulating your
mom?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So you want to scam your mom? I'm going
to not scare my mom. I will call her right now and say, "Okay,
you can mute right now." I'm going to call her and say, "What?"
>> My phone's dead.
>> All right, we'll take it to 15.
>> that's a piss. >> Hold on.
>> Dude, sorry. People are doing Photoshops. They're doing
edits. Okay, this is apparently Fancy Sloth and his
Free Halloween party with my dark queen. She went full Morticia.
a Jacob post that Morticia is getting piped tonight. Tonight.
Why? Why are you guys doing this? I guarantee this is getting
spammed in Darius's comments. It's like everywhere. That's not
Hannah. No, that's the girl Fancy Sloth was was with. It does
look a little like Hannah, though. Same vibes,
man. I
I can't believe how rattled Darius is going to be in this.
>> It's rough. >> My thumb.
Wait, the
>> No, thanks.
>> I can't do it.
>> That's what they said. That's what they >> No,
you're just No. Stop. Please stop. Please stop. Please stop.
I'm going to crash the car. The [__] was that? >> Not
BTD. Not BPD. Not BPD. Don't be
just manipulative. Look, you're
doing you're doing it like you're being your mother.
>> You nipple with your mom.
>> She got she was mad at me. But she's like, "Oh,
you're telling me something but not everything. You're not telling
the truth." Like
>> another [laughter] chick controller. Daryl classic.
>> I don't even dude I don't I I'll be
>> He's watching this and getting like more depressed as
he watches it. There are literally 50 handles on Tinder and Hinge.
Let me pull my hinge on.
>> I bet they have supportive girlfriends in their lives.
They probably have supportive situationships. Uh
Mr. B. >> The following contest is scheduled for
making it way to the ring from Canada, weighing in at 217
LBS. the WWE
Intercontinental
>> Crazy situation for that guy. Okay. Anyway,
RIP. RIP is the word to use there. All right. We'll be back with
uh BC Games, by the way. We're waiting uh for our next reload.
So, you do gambling streams. You need to buy the goat back. That's
where things went south. We we need to go back to doing content.
But here's here's here's my calendar in
So, here's where I'm going to be at. Okay.
So, sometime either here or here,
I'm going to do my walk through
uh for my warrant, I believe somewhere on this date or this date.
>> Wait, was he back
after TwitchCon? Was he back in Austin for this or No, it probably
got delayed, right? He was talking about them getting delayed
all the time. >> My walk through. I'm released from jail
the same day here or here.
>> Then it's Halloween.
>> and I need to be driving at this point
>> He was he was driving to Austin when he got arrested
in Oklahoma.
Bro, his his getting arrested is really interfering with him
serving his time for his original warrant that's out for his
arrest.
I see. walkth through must mean you have to like technically
spend a day or two in jail because they're going to process you
somehow.
>> It's like the all the time he's having to spend dealing
with his previous crimes are affecting him serving his time for
his previous crimes. >> Latex suit now, dude. Like he's
like, >> I'm going to go to [__] I >> Oh,
he's listening to a Hannah Tik Tok in the background, right?
>> I have to spend Halloween in Arizona.
>> Yeah.
And I'm gonna I'm gonna jump off a [__] cliff.
>> Uhhuh. He's definitely This is definitely a Hannah Tik
Tok right now based on the zone out.
>> you should never go back to Arizona. Well, I drive by
Arizona.
>> Oh, Fuji hitting him with the Fuji hitting him with
the hardcore truths right now. You should never go back to Arizona.
Hannah doesn't love you. She doesn't want you.
>> Surely Darius will accept accept these
to stay in Arizona for the day. Dude, imagine we stream in Arizona
and we run into her. I will literally I'm not even joking. That
will I will 12 gauge my head off. I'm not even joking. On stream,
I will I will run into a pawn shop and just grab it. I don't
care. Get me in a police shootout. I don't give a
Oh, and I know it's going to happen. It will happen cuz we go
to the same exact bars on Halloween night. Unless she goes to
a party
on the stream. There's no way Darius is gonna be able to watch
cutie Cinderella >> I hate this chick so much. >> I
feel like there's no way he could watch this for Yeah, he watched
it for like 10 minutes. >> Voice is whiny. >> Yeah,
he can't do it. >> Chat, do you want slow mot?
>> That's fine. I get it. I get why it was difficult for
him.
>> Trust me, this was hard for me to even sit through.
This was this was horrifying the whole time. >> Something
like this. >> Is Darius from Arizona originally? I don't
know where he's from originally. No, I have no idea.
No clue that. I believe that wraps up the Darius content. Okay,
guys. I think that that's a wrap for the most rec Oh, wait. I
lied. I actually just lied to you. That's not a wrap for the
most recent Darius content. Apparently, Darius went live again
today. Wait, hold on. What?
Yeah, he went live again today. 30-minute VOD. He went live
>> doing white face.
Darius literally just got called black by the cops. Okay. The
cops acknowledged his blackness. Wait, where do I have the tweet?
I don't have the tweet here. Hold on. Where's my Where's my tweet?
What did I do with it? What did I do with this tweet? There it
is. They just acknowledged his blackness. Okay, I think it's
over here. Race.
Race. Black. Race. Black.
And he immediately goes to do white face.
Why?
>> What's he going, folks? Strike up going over there.
Oh, usually visiting back
>> I will say Gasam has the better clubs but there is a
more more variety of >> I might try to get back live tonight
guys. We might go back to the hotel after the show and then I'll
go live with them
>> like this. >> I look good, dude.
>> Hey, give me all the time. >> I am disappointed
at the rush. >> No, I look good.
I look handsome. Wait, hold on. >> You look like the I
like turtles kid. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. What did you just link me? What did you just link other
people? Top Ronson. What is this? What is this?
>> Mary Kirby and let her be the bread winner. Do you know
how up that would be? Although she would like that. I wouldn't
like that. I want to be the bread winner.
>> well, I want to be equal at least. >> Hold on.
I need to restart this cuz I can't go forward. We're like
I well >> I want to be equal at least
>> I think I'm honestly really scared
with Kirby cuz I think if me and Kirby started dating it would
just be over. I think that's it. That's literally it. We're just
we're like like there's no
Did you see Impath Jam was hanging out in Destiny's apartment
while he was gone making blackface videos? Nope.
Sounds about par for the course. Really? There just isn't much
for conduct that can be shocking anymore, right? Like he just
transparently lies about how close he is to people. He just obviously
totally full of in like every way. I don't know. It's like actually
just it I couldn't be any less shocked.
Um
it's just funny to watch the people around him and how they act
>> like throw away the key. >> He's like he's become
uh how do I explain it? I don't know if I've had anyone like
this cuz Darius stays interesting. Darius somehow stays interesting
to me. Destiny's like become totally boring.
It's kind of like the Pirate Software thing. Like I'll maybe
cover court case docs or whatever. I I know like the people there.
So it's not totally boring all the time, but like his conduct
in terms of the things he does to like rage bait, it just does
nothing. It's all so predictable. It's so boring.
>> Yeah, it's so predictable. It's so boring. I don't know
how to explain it. Like that's just not shocking at all.
Pride's offer is still content when he gets into Yeah, but does
he get into [__] anymore? I don't know.
>> There's no purpose of dating again. That's probably
like a small portion of
because we would just be
we would just be so like locked in.
>> he's literally entertaining the idea of dating Hannah
two days ago. >> Lose all this.
>> He later meets up with Kerbine in his >> Is that
what you want? Wait, he's not in
Am I Is this mirrored? Is he driving right now or is it like
Herbine who's driving? There's no shot Kerbine's driving while
he says this, right?
That would be beyond
crazy. Okay. Okay. Okay. Herbine can't be in the car while he
talks about this. >> Take it from me. What would you know?
>> Okay. Anyway, it dude, we'll we'll continue on with
the white face spot. >> Say it. >> What happened
to your beard? >> I don't know. That took it all apart.
>> Matt Maltese tour for my whole life.
did we hear about this before where he had like sent her tickets?
Your ticket transfer to Hannah for the Matt Multi tour for you
my whole life. Dude,
>> what are we going to get? Are we going to get more Are
we going to get more content out of me watching Darius's like
web his browser history than the actual video? I tried to send
>> that the crash out. The Hannah crash out video was yours,
Ry. >> I saw it in there as well >> to Matt Maltise.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> On October 26th. Why did you do this? >> Hey,
spoiler, guys.
She didn't even get them.
>> She didn't even take them. >> Just leak everything
I [__] all day,
Oh, it's brutal. I think it' be coming on a mail or you know
what I'm thinking I'm thinking what happened is genuinely I think
here's I think genuinely here's what happened. Why? What is this?
>> Uh let's see what this is. All of this doesn't matter.
I hung out with Murk during scavenger hunt because I was honestly
just wanted to get through this event because it was stressful
as and wanted it over. Fix this situation or I'm not helping
you. That's all. If you need to help you can reach out or if
you need help you can reach out. Maybe you saw some out of context
clips or things I said out of anger. When I heard you were arrested,
I did cry on stream and I did tell people it's not a means to
celebrate. I just I don't wish that or whatever I went through
onto anyone. I talked to Kimmy about bailing you out and tried
helping her and even offered to help front cost if they need
anything. I've been proactive.
I've been rude at times because I'm hurt just like you are. A
lot of everything that has happened is pretty brutal. We are
at the point where you are trying to hurt me out of pure spite.
If you want me, if you want my help, I will provide it. But I
cannot help with things like this around. So I think this must
be to Zena, right? This must be to Zena from him. I think like
he's trying to Yeah, I I assume this is Darius to Zena as well
that basically he's like asking her to drop everything and saying
like, "Hey, I'm sorry I said things out of anger and I wasn't
MK's not somebody I seriously care about or whatever." Yeah.
See what he says. Nothing.
Oh, he doesn't say anything because it's about Zena,
>> right?
If it wasn't about if it was about somebody else, then he would
>> 0 to 18. I got all my hobbies and interests. So, like
Sasuke and then Destiny. I like Destiny, but I Destiny.
>> I'm trying to get through to where he starts talking.
>> I was like, "Bro, you're the most boring human being
ever. How do you watch this?" But ask me ask me to turn on ask
me to turn on anything and I'm not I'm not going to turn turn
it on. Like I'm not I have not I know I have nothing else I can
listen to. This is something that I'd be like oh I pull someone
over and I'm like hey let's watch night changes and watch Z Malik
look good as and handsome as I wish I looked like this man. >> something
that's what I would do. >> This is weird. >> I've
been playing Ghost of Yai. That's a pretty fun game. >> Hey
skip it forward. Skipping back forward again.
Hit up your best butt, Jackie. Didn't you used to chill with
him?
Is this
who? Oh, are you are you repeating that?
Dude, there's this guy I was trying to say that I was hanging
out with Jacko Herie. Who's this stupid monkey? Also, by dude,
I So, I was messaging. So, I've been here's what I've been doing
now. Okay,
my new strat now is I realized real girls won't work for me anymore,
right? So, we need to move on to Twitter girls or other streamer
girls. Then I was like, "Okay, >> you've literally tried
Twitter girls before, bro. You've tried all of this. Jesus Christ."
>> Crazy. No more. No more gooning.
>> We skip. We skip. We skip. Vote to skip. Vote to skip.
Vote to skip. Omi XC's brother's XC's brother's girlfriend.
>> dude? What is her name?
>> Some absolute garbage content here in the middle of
everything. >> Little Alley. There we go. >> We wanted
to look up XC's brother's
except somebody who looks very young. Very cool.
>> All these people are tangentially dead to me. The people
I loved, the ideas,
>> the the personalities, they don't exist. >> Hold
on. Actually, I I just skipped through a bunch of that rant.
Going
>> Going back.
>> Story producer,
story writer. And they were using me as their main character.
Does that make >> No. But I'm not going to go back to fill
in the context. >> Hey, guess what? You need Glink.
I will hang out with Glink very soon.
>> Very soon. New script. Here we come. >> Oh my
god, dude. >> Not a new script. I just don't romanticize
ghost and man. Holy. You were genued into love. Yes, I was
>> into Listen, Hannah.
>> I never thought I would feel anything towards her.
>> Objective. Objectively a lie. >> Going into it,
I was like, "This chick's just hot."
>> Uh, you know, we don't really like
Well, we do get along.
>> Yeah, he's objectively lying. He's just objectively
lying. >> Okay. Well, I didn't think I was gonna like her
anyway because, you know, I was getting over my ex
and, you know,
I didn't I didn't try to date her like two years ago, so I thought
I try to date her now.
Then she started saying stuff. She started making conditions
and I and I played into the genjutsu
and then I started believing the
at a certain point when I should have kept my attitude at the
beginning because once you start switching up that's when they
have to reassess the new personality.
the [__] is this guy saying? Red flag.
>> What is he saying? Yeah. Poor buddy
or baby
or tiny. >> Literally got no idea what this guy's talking
about >> at all.
That's him. Okay. Okay.
>> He's got his sad boy music going. There's only like
two more minutes in the vibe. >> I sometimes wear a bandana.
I see a red flag and I
>> Sorry, I skipped past. Try not to waste too much time
on this. >> You keep ignoring red flags. I'm not going
to ignore red flags. Here's the thing. I see red flag and I just
play with the red flag. I I dance with it. I use it as underwear.
I sometimes wear it as bandana. Uh I don't mind the red flag
because everyone can have red flags. Look at me. Look at
I'm a walking red flag. Me being live right now is a red flag.
These headphones are a red flag.
This mustache is a red flag.
>> You need to do [laughter] something, bro. You can't
just go live and talk about Hannah and get upset. Like these
type of guys I just want to beat the [__] out of.
You know what I mean? They just think like they're so happy.
Like this is my endgame.
>> Bro, if those guys are gay, they're super happy. I'm
sorry. That's just
Like, you want me to act like this?
Is this what you guys want me to act like? I act like everything
is okay all the time.
It might be okay for these guys cuz they have all their bros
with them if you notice that.
>> Is it actually woman? Is it actually woman's fault?
>> Her for a lot of other people that's possible. Not for
Darius. It's It's just all Darius's fault in this case. Okay.
>> What did provide? Not really. >> That's so close.
>> I just I just really enjoyed her company. Like I I wanted
to be more like her. I guess I think I see myself
in these people more
or I see traits from them that I really want or I see I I think
I understand them at least.
I don't really know how to explain. Like sushi. I was in love
with Sushi
uh when I first met her and we did everything and it's because
I really like the way she was and I saw
something I always wanted to have around me for the rest of my
life.
And then >> Uh-huh. Uh,
Zena as well. I saw something I saw something with her that I
really wanted to have around for the rest of my life, which was
this like one specific thing. I can't remember what it was. It
was funny.
Uh, and then once I once I see that thing and I lock in and then
I'm like in the relationship thing, I just get a little I get
psychotic, but I don't get like bad psych I don't get psychotic
to the levels that I personally would start calling the police
for,
which if you look at my rap history, my rap sheet, I haven't
really called the police on anybody. So,
not But you guys get what I'm saying.
Like, what? You guys get what I'm saying? Like I'll do some stalking.
Like some some light stalking. Some light looking around because
I [laughter] miss
>> Okay. Uh. Uh-huh. Listen, just I
It's like a little Other people would call this stalking, but
it's because they don't understand that I'm like I just can't
get it out of my mind. Like I I can't get it out of my mind,
so I have to keep looking at all of their stuff all the time.
And other people would call this stalking, but it's just cuz
they don't get that. I'm like, I never do anything. I just like
have to my brain just needs a little bit. I need to see what
happens and then I'm okay, but then I'm not okay. And I need
to watch again. I need to look at their social media again. But
it's not stalking. >> But I don't think I'm going to be
too bad. The only person I think I've been >> it's not
stalking.
>> Awful too in terms of that is I was say maybe Sushi,
but nah, she deserves
>> was Danny. I don't look at what Danny's doing in the
side. >> Yeah. You don't take it to the sub levels where
you do a wellness check because they blocked you. There you go.
Okay, that's what I'm saying. So like like I had a situation
where like my uh like well my last ex everyone already know what
they did. >> Wait, is that what I thought Hassan was genuinely
concerned about his one ex? I thought he was like genuinely concerned.
I've never heard that that he just did it because she wasn't
talking to him. >> Uh I'm not doing anything like that.
Doing a wellness check on someone because they they block me
and I'm like pretending I'm like scared for their mental health.
I when when even when my ex or whatever needed a wellness check,
I would just tell the other people like, "Hey, you have to call
the wellness check." Unless I was like getting berated, like
there was one time I was getting bered by literally like 10 people
and I was like, "Okay, I'll call the wellness checks since none
of you people will do it." But I'm not going to call wellness
checks just because I want to know if you're like some guy or
I just want to hear from you in some way. >> Not what Hassan
did either. Get crazy. Like yesterday, I was going to kill myself
if I had a gun, but I didn't do that because uh I didn't have
a gun and I also don't know how to tie a knot. So, I don't and
I don't know where I would hate myself from.
>> I've always recommended Darius purchase a firearm with
and they don't want a gun because they're poor. So, and I can't
buy a gun anymore. So,
too stupid to die. I I would have to drive really fast and hit
something. But like my my thing is like the the process of my
my car takes at least 5 seconds to get to 60.
So, in those 5 seconds, I'm like what? If my car took literally
less than a second to get to 60, I get myself.
But because the car takes 5 seconds to get to 60, I have too
much time to reconsider my decision.
You know that one there's like a book there's like a book or
something. There's like a poem about the long way down or something
where like the guy's like falling down and he's like, "Oh,
what [snorts] did I do?" Imagine you had no whip. Uh, if I had
no whip,
I would never have done the scavenger hunt. So, I wouldn't be
in this
So,
the view from halfway down. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh, it's a Bojack thing. Why did I think it was
like
Why did I think this was something from something like inspirational
car? I'd be dead. So,
uh, this my
Okay. So, I met this girl. I was like, dude, this has to be a
streamer. Why do why does she look so familiar? We're watching
until we're going to get rants about different stuff. What does
scavenger hunt do? Oh, he got in trouble at the afterparty for
scavenger hunt, I believe, is where I believe the afterparty
for scavenger hunt is where he spitting Zena's face, right? I
think >> My face is getting so bloated, dude. I cannot
wait. >> Like the one where he did like the llama like
over and over again. I think that was an afterparty for Scavenger.
Huh? >> Who's this girl?
>> Oh, that's CO, right? >> I think she just cuckoo.
Yeah, >> she just exposed Msk. Msk. [laughter] She exposed
Msk or something recently. >> Yeah, thank you. It's so
cool that Darius found her on on a dating app. >> So bloated,
dude. >> Darius finds her on a dating app and is immediately
like, you know what? Let's get her entire profile on here. Yeah,
let's go. University of Houston.
>> Who's this girl? >> Wow. Okay, it's actually not
that much. >> I think she just cuckoo.
She also exposed Msk. Msk.
She exposed
>> Is that even actually her though? That's almost certainly
her. >> So that's >> I understand like Oh, sorry.
You're saying it's could be somebody catfishing. That picture
is her cuz it's like got the exact same filter she uses on stream.
>> That's cool.
>> So she does it. She likes Okay, I'm black. So,
but she's 34 years old, which is great. That's fine. That's 5
years older than me. Uh, so that's fine.
You're finally moving on from mid Miami fives. Who's a mid Miami?
Dude, every girl I've ever talked to has been beautiful. Look
at my rash feet. Like, who have like any girl that I've been
in love with has been beautiful.
Uh,
>> he's just immediately he immediately first person that
he goes to type in is Hannah. Like instantly.
>> Uh-huh. Realized realized that he shouldn't type Hannah
he shouldn't start typing Hannah in into his browser. So you
can see what's popping up. Okay.
On tiny baby bunny on Tik Tok.
Hi something. Hold on. What was that? >> Like any girl
squeeze.
Hold on. Do we see it? Did we see it? I might have gone by too
quickly. We'll watch again.
>> The knowers know. The knowers saw it instantly. Hold
on. >> Every girl I've ever talked to. >> This is
uh >> beautiful. Look at my rash. Like
what do we have? >> Wait. Let's see it pop up here. Right
here. Bottom bottom link. Bottom link, guys. He's not He's not
obsessive. He doesn't saw. It's fine. It's fine. >> Girl
I've been in love with is >> I I'm not talking about that
one. What the It's an old bookmark.
This guy's a This guy's a weirdo.
Uh >> two old. [laughter]
Okay. He's been stalking Danny on
Realizes, "Hey, I should stop leaking
My god. My god. >> Just check Hannah's repost on Tik Tok.
All right. Now that we're done with that, your victim's in full
display.
I can't pull up the one that has her training order on me, but
I mean Sushi used to look great. God, she looks like Hulk Hogan
in this. >> Why? Why would you say that? >> Food.
Let me find a one that's more appetizing. You know, these photos
aren't the greatest.
They look good. This is a good video,
>> Look at her recent streams. Hell no.
She's like past 25 now. >> Hey, Sushi. She looks cute here.
She >> Oh, I I really hope Kerbi doesn't see this one.
She's like past 25 now. Oh >> Don't be like
>> she's from like a trailer park. But like she'll
Hannah obviously. Oh,
>> your ticket transferred to Hannah is on the way for
>> She's like very likewise Democrat.
hates everything. >> Yeah. Very like what is it called?
>> Like upper upper class upper upper class liberal [__]
like yeah let the gay gay but like don't put them in the same
>> I'm not my mom's marriage. is allowed to be liber
and she's
>> kill Jeff Thomas by pushing him off the balcony in 2023.
>> Is that true?
>> I'm looking to skip forward for the sushia content >> cuz
the last one was really nice. You should have >> the last
toilet.
>> I told him you were doing tequila shots with Kirby twerking
on you and he started tweaking.
>> These cheeks look fat.
You know what that means? Youth. So he crashes out. I really
don't want him to crash out. >> Is there a way I can?
>> Like should I start wearing suit every time I drive
so they don't pull me over? >> Um you know what I was wearing
when we got pulled over?
>> Uh you were talking about like maybe like switching
to like more more Korean style. Yeah. So that that helps.
>> Um I think that's why I was not tested. >> Why
did you get contacts to look like Hanner? Uh, first of all,
>> she was immediately offended. He immediately finds that
so funny. Oh god. Is this the new This is like the new Darius
stare right here. Dude,
what the
He found that so funny instantly. And he's like trying to bite
his tongue. He's biting his tongue while he laughs right here.
That's what's happening. >> Put this in the thing. >> There's
no one who has like eyes like this. Second of all, >> what
about that lightkinned guy on
>> I don't know what that means. >> First second
of all, second of all, I was doing I was doing cosplay.
>> There we go. >> Did you get the tuzu bra? >> You
did? >> Wait, do you have it in your luggage? >> You
got to show chat it.
>> The tazuyu bra, guys. Have you seen the tuzi bra? >> This
is the Soer. Soer.
>> Soiler. Watch out. She has sucky by eyes. She >> Hold
on. Play the meme in general. What is this?
Oh, you guys had a Oh, I see. [laughter]
>> I think that's why I was not tested. >> Get contacts
to look like Hanner,
>> dude. That's crazy. Stop. Stop. Stop. Okay, we're fine
again. I got a little dicey there with Charlie for a second.
Okay, that was that was crazy. But >> we're safe. We're
safe.
>> Have you guys seen the tuzi you brought? It goes hard.
First of all, it's
Zoe. Zoe. >> Yeah, that's that's how you pronounce
>> Guys, check out this bra.
>> You know that's a push-up, right?
>> Somebody somebody threw up this this meme in the in
the chat as well. Okay. Not as not as high effort, but still
good.
What is this? M. I think that's Keropene. Zena, Sushia, Hannah,
Grace.
There's like many, many more that could go on this. Okay.
There's many, many
What's crazy is the 3,000 will be attacked right off supporting
you. >> All right. Can I see this? Can I see the address,
the location? >> Hander one. >> How much longer to
Sure, she did. Dude, >> this is She's giving away that
she's like super tilted by the Hannah memes